members of the public to observe and
listen contemporariously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaries
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has access to contemporaries
listening and if necessary participate
in the meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271
3600 or email hcs at ledge.state.nh
us in the event the public is unable to
access this meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance with each member states
their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is required on the right
to know law
okay you're on right calling the roll
representative hunts yes i am here all
alone
representative patousek i am here
and i am home alone representative
osborne
representative ammond here alone
representative ham here alone
representative greeson president alone
representative you're in the lob alone
president terry uh present and alone in
representative bartlett i am here in my
home in this room alone representative
abel
uh present and no one else in the room
representative herbert
uh president in this room uh we have
three people working
on wi-fi so i may get bumped off at any
moment
but i'm here alone in this room
representative van halton
here alone representative fargo
i'm here and i'm alone representative
weston here in my office alone
representative bell you here home alone
representative burroughs i'm here my
husband is also here but he's going to
be leaving shortly
and representative mcaleer
chris where are you i see him but it's
funny
he just got moved over you might need a
second
thank you i'm here alone and i don't
know why i've been on
for five minutes and i'm just showing up
now
i don't get it it's probably the wrong
link there's two there's
two different links this happens to me
uh so we have 16 president mr chair
that's the rule
okay great we'll open up the public
hearing on set of bill 35
and hear from the private sponsor
senator cavanaugh good morning senator
chairman members thank you for having me
i hope everyone's been enjoying this
beautiful weather this week
my name is kevin cavanaugh i represent
district 16 senate district 16
the towns of beau candidate dunbarton
hooksett and manchester awards 1 2 and
12.
and just here to introduce senate bill
in 1995 schoolcare was founded by five
new hampshire educational
organizations and the purpose of school
care was to provide school employees
with access to more affordable health
care options
when the life and health insurance risk
pool program was created by school care
nea new hampshire was the only founding
member excluded from participating in it
therefore this bill would allow anya new
hampshire to participate
in the existing risk pool program only
after having gained
approval from the governing board of the
risk pool
significantly this bill is narrowly
tailored tailored to prevent
any unintended unintended expansion
of who can participate in the risk pool
program programs that are covered under
rsa
5-b and we did work it was last year
with the secretary of state's office on
this language to make sure it was very
finely tuned
and it did go through the senate
commerce and a 5-0 vote and was on the
consent calendar calendar in the senate
as well
and i can take any questions
mr chairman thank you uh representative
bartlett has a question
thanks very much mr chair and thanks for
coming to see us um senator cavanaugh
i'm sorry i missed when the um school
care was
organized in 1995 95
okay thank you very much thank you
so this means like for instance teachers
or aft teachers who are
eligible but the nea teachers were not
correct nea is the only founding member
member organization that was excluded
for whatever
reason they weren't included in it so it
would just be for that for that group to
be added in
and it's got to be the government party
of the board still has to say yes to it
just by passing this it still gives them
the authority to say yes or no
right so i guess other than those two
what other teacher unions that are in
this
association um you know i'm not even
sure i'd have to probably defer that to
um i think ryan hawkins might be
testifying maybe yep
you see him all right great uh
seeing no more questions thank you very
much okay i'm going to jump off i have
an e dna meeting but i wish i had to
have a good meeting a good scene
everyone
we'll see and
i'm going to promote barry glennon who
is the secretary of state's division of
securities which
i guess it is the secretary of state
that
has oversight over risk pools and i know
he's kind of delegated some of that
activity to securities
good morning mr chair are you able to uh
hear me okay yes we can
terrific thank you my name is barry
glennon with the
new hampshire secretary of state's
office bureau securities regulation
which we have
regulatory oversight of risk pool
programs
just as senator kavanaugh indicated the
bureau
we did meet with senator cavanaugh last
year
to discuss this and uh as he indicated
um this is really very narrowly tailored
um
and uh in order for a member
uh to be able to participate in this
pool it does require the approval of the
governing board so there is some
oversight there
uh and so in effect we we support
sb 35 and encourage its passage
any questions we have the answers so so
why did it require legislation to allow
why couldn't the board just vote
vote to have more members
i believe was the the language uh in uh
5b uh that did not actually uh
include them uh which is the reason why
senator kavanaugh was asked to
pursue an amendment to 5b
okay any other questions for
mr moon seeing none thank you very much
okay thank you mr chair
thank you so now brian hawkins who uh
[Music]
thank you mr chairman uh and thank you
for having me
um can you hear me okay yes we can okay
terrific
uh uh mr chairman members of the
house commerce committee for the record
my name is brian hawkins
i'm zooming before you today
representing nea new hampshire
we represent over 17 000 members
across new hampshire in collective
bargaining and um
many of the amazing educators in public
education
today in our state as senator cavanaugh
explained
26 years ago school care was founded as
the new hampshire school care coalition
and it
uh and by the way i i will uh i have
some written testimony i will also
submit
um to the committee and to the clerk so
uh thank you
just to say that at the top um and so it
was founded when the
executive director of nea new hampshire
at the time
approached the school boards association
and some of the other associations
representing
management in school districts to
respond to what they felt was the need
to have another choice
when accessing healthcare for school
employees
as well as to hopefully have some more
affordable options
for health insurance something that
would benefit school districts
employees and taxpayers so the
partnership was founded by the
association of school business officials
the new hampshire school boards
association
nea new hampshire the school board's
insurance trust
and the new hampshire school
administrators association um
the goal uh and the premise of this was
this uh coalition was to have a true
labor management enterprise in seeking
to provide
again districts and and other political
subdivisions
um options that were a good fit for them
for their health care
and over the last uh 25 26 years we feel
the coalition has been a truly
successful one a collaborative one and
one that's uh
worked well toward what it wasn't
intended to do again that
a labor management part partnership um
and today the na new hampshire president
continues to sit on the board of school
care
and we continue to have new hampshire
indianapolis continues to have a
you know staff person dedicated to
helping uh
facilitate that process uh especially
for the for the labor side
in um in and helping our members with
their
uh health insurance
needs so now of the founding members
that i just mentioned
as senator kavanaugh said there's only
one of those organizations
that cannot participate in the risk pool
as an employer
for their own employees and that is nea
new hampshire
um um and that's because of the way the
5b
statute is currently written so i think
um
just to clarify that it this is uh
because i think that uh mr chairman you
asked the question of uh
senator kavanaugh uh so this is uh
that any a new hampshire as an employer
would be participating
in um in the risk in
the rest pool so the teachers are
already in
teachers are already covered you just
want the management of nda
to be else to also be covered under this
pool
so this so uh actually this is this was
the next point i was going to make my
testimony but
it was actually uh so um
so if you are the the way the
statute is currently uh written um
you're asking uh mr glennon earlier
um it's sort of a broad definition that
includes
any of the entities that are sort of
created by some of the
the other you know town
school district so for example if you
are
uh the new hampshire school boards or
school administrators association
you you are inc they are included as an
employer in the definition of who can
participate
in a 5b risk pool plan
those other partners in founding school
care and continuing to
you know sit on the board of school care
they
all are able to participate for
that as employers as well so not just
the school districts that they represent
but the school boards
association for example as an employer
can participate
in the plan same thing goes for health
trust with respect to the municipal
association
so so so again if there's only one
left out of that and that simply has to
do with the definition of
of of or the way the statute was written
so it wasn't necessarily
specifically including or excuse me
excluding us
as a is just the the categories of of
who could be included
and so the bill seeks to correct this
issue by allowing
founding organizations of risk pool
management programs
to participate in specifically just the
health and life insurances so i'll point
out
in the bill it specifically references
just
um 5b 3 roman 3 f
and g and so this does not include
this does not include workers
compensation or anything
else like that is just a the health and
life
so um again this legislation is is
is is really about acknowledging the
integral role that
a founding organization of a risk will
like any of new hampshire's played in
the formation and success of school care
by
by fixing this um provision in in the
statute
um as has
been stated it is narrowly tailored so
we would have to receive
authorization from the board
not the nda new hampshire board but the
uh
the board of school care which has a
fiduciary responsibility to
the pool um in order to uh
in order to participate um
and so throughout this process uh i just
want to uh
thank uh uh the secretary of state's
office uh secretary gardner mr glenn
for for their uh uh assistance as well
as
uh you know the folks at school care
uh for working with us on this and for
uh senate and to senator cavanaugh for
bringing the bill forward
so i'll close my testimony there and
again i'll i'll
i will submit um my written version of
this
to the committee for the record and
okay so i'm still i still make sure i
want to answer
so again i'm using my example as the aft
which is the other big teachers union
right so aft wasn't barred because
their representatives were actual
teachers and therefore they were getting
the benefits
or that right out of the beginning you
know it was
how how did well against first is there
aft members
in this in this risk pool
um i i presume there are school
districts who have you know
uh school employees represented by aft
that
are in the risk pool
okay um so it's it's not the um
it is not the actual educators
school staff that are excluded so our
members certainly are not excluded from
if their employer joins the pool okay
so that means i guess what i think
you're saying
is that the nea is so big that it has
employees that are not
actually teachers and
you would like them to be able to join
in this risk pool
simply because they work for the nea and
they're not teacher even though they're
not teachers
uh yes uh you know so we we
any new hampshire would have to
participate as an employer for their
employees but
but yes i think i think you're i think
that's right
got it okay um and i just say just as
just as the other associations
that are part of this plan can do right
now so
okay so let's say you with some of the
other ones you met you mentioned school
boards
yeah so that means that anybody who's on
is a school board could get in on this
policy even though
they're elected and only there for a
couple of years
no so you would have to be it would be
an employee
or as an employee the school boards
association
as um you know a
small number of employees i think so as
as as an employer
um they can they can buy into school
care for their employees
because they're not it's not which might
might have about 10 employees i mean i
don't know
how they have right we also yes and
that's exactly right and so any new
hampshire has a
you know we have less than 20 employees
who else is yeah so read that list again
not going to pay more
oh sure uh so um the
member and this will be in my uh this is
part of my testimony too so you have
the school business officials the school
boards association
us uh the school boards uh and the
new hampshire school administrators
association though
uh that'd be like the superintendent the
superintendents and
but again it's for their employees not
for the
so to cite the example you use
a school a member of a school board
would not be eligible
for this it would only be uh
the the the the employees who have a
full-time job of working for
these the associations right exactly
holy moly well i guess the awkwardness
is that that
we money some of us think the nea is a
uh and i know it's supposed to be
advancement of teachers
but we think of as a union so what we're
doing is we're taking the union office
and we're saying
we're going to treat you just like a
teacher so that's
that's that's simply an interesting
sorry yes thank you
as i understand this bill tell me if i'm
correct
well it would be necessary for the
legislature
to pass this bill and the governor to
sign it in order
to expand who's eligible
to participate there
in no way does this affect taxpayers
that is uh there's there's no there's no
cost to the taxpayer could could you
just
address if that's if that is correct
uh that that's absolutely correct um
and uh i think there may be a
representative in the
uh uh in the
audience the virtual audience of from
school care if you wanted to hear from
them as well
but um you know we we would obviously
like any other
you know school district or other
employer
was participating would actually have to
pay our pay the full cost of
participating so so you're absolutely
correct
there's no cost to the state or to the
locality
representative van halen thank you mr
chair good morning thank you mr hawkins
for being here
i just like to clarify something too i
think some of us are going in directions
that may or may not be the right
directions and i'd like to just be 100
sure first of all we're talking about a
small number of employees who probably
should have been there in the first
place
and had did not get residents in that
pool am i correct
yeah i think that's a fair assessment
yes and secondly
this is totally divorced from anything
union related this is simply a matter of
doing the right thing by employees and
offering them this kind of coverage is
that correct as well
that's correct again you know this is
this is correcting the only
the only group that is making this a
successful
uh you know enterprise the school is not
able to participate
okay any other questions from the
committee
uh great so is anybody the attendees
does anybody else would like to testify
thank you thank you very much mr
chairman i appreciate your time and i'll
i'll get this
written stuff over to you thank you very
much
so i i don't have anybody else signed up
for it and
uh and i don't see any hands popping up
uh who want to want to testify so i
guess
we will end the public hearing on
senate bill 35 and we had nine
support and not opposed and
nobody neutral so with that we'll close
the public hearing on senate bill 35
all right what's next
oh if you're looking for that piece of
paper not like so what's the next one
the next one is at 9 45 and it's senate
bill 38.
okay all right so that one
all right well i guess we we're going to
be brief set recess until 9 45.
yeah i'm looking at the old one you're
you're right calendar has 9 45.
oh all right schedule it came out
yeah the revised schedule is 9 45. right
okay the uh what have was there was some
bills
that didn't didn't appear so we had to
work around it
right right because i like i say i have
9 30
but that was okay
so um okay so
we'll just in brief recess until uh the
if the calendar says nine for the key
elements the calendar
so if the calendar says 9 45 then yeah
it says 9 45 on the calendar okay so
that that's that's the rules
we play by okay you all
you guys in the committee rooms i guess
what you have to do is turn
off your volume on your computers
because you've got the speaker in the
room
right we i would mine as long as low as
it will go it won't
shut off anymore so i don't have my
speaker on in my
and on my i think it's your it's your
microphone right so it's not speaker
[Music]
i don't know that's a good question
sounds like a cricket
yeah it does feels like late summer
already
right i think if you go to the bottom
well in my my screen and you go
to the speaker you can actually turn it
off
right or maybe the f1 keep
i got my tablet tablet
[Music]
so max is it doing to yours too are you
having the same problem
let me let me go out and come back in
and try that no i have a laptop so it i
um so so you have an ipad
done or is it a kindle tablet
tablet is that a google device
what is a tablet i'm not sure i know
tablet is that hp
or
it's android so yeah it's an android
right so it's a google
google some type developments yeah
samsung
samsung oh okay cool samsung yeah you
should be able to turn it off
they keep trying to get me to take buy
one of those
mr chair yes i um did receive in the
mail
the printed um bills that were dealing
with yesterday and today of course it
came yesterday afternoon
but uh one was missing and we don't have
any for next week
so um would be your suggestion that i go
to the clerk's office and ask them
to mail the bills out to us
my memory was that bills were always the
responsibility of the
sergeant of arms are you around him
yeah i am i mean you know this is a
sort of different situation where
our our office has been mailing them out
but only on requests
you know we haven't we tried to do that
automatic mailing early in january but
a lot of the bills weren't printed yet
so it created
you know it wasn't smooth and to do the
um rings right
you know we don't have like like mailing
lists sorted by committee we had them
sorted alphabetically for the whole 400
and
anyway it was um you know as you can
understand a big shore so we've been
doing them
on requests for the senate bills and
but the mail is not you know as quick as
it
once was so well i hoped in concord she
can get them pretty quickly
yeah i know i know it would happen
i mean everything comes from manchester
united or nashville whatever the big
circle
exactly well i mean that's the thing i
mean representative bartlett
they were mailed out i remember the
discussion i don't remember which day
but it certainly wasn't
friday you know no they didn't they no
so yeah it's actually a lobbyist who's
calling me
so our office is the short answer is
that our office is the right place to go
okay um we do our best but you know if
people can pick them up that's fantastic
that's clearly an
option i'm sure she can pick them up
yeah yeah or she can do that for you
right that
that makes sense we'd love to be able to
you know get them immediately to
everybody but it's
it's trickier than you might first right
and don you were able to get that
big report for the liquor commission by
picking it up right don
yes she did she did and she got the um
status report when she was in yesterday
or monday so
coming to concord excellent we can do
that
well i hope to be there soon to be there
soon
hi i'm i'm i'm assuming by
by uh may
everybody will have been vaccinated so
so um so should
i mean if i if i request these bills
and go down to the security office in
the state house
could they have an envelope of those
bills for me
absolutely that you could go to the lob
reception desk
you know we could make an arrangement
okay so are you making that request
right now
i am i um i'd like the bills for next
week
sure that would be great and um
you can just let me know when they're
ready and i can stop by but i believe
the rest of our
committee members would like them to be
mailed out to them for next week
okay i'll put that request in right now
so i can start working on it you know
i'm i'm in the office so that's an easy
thing
okay we'll do our best thanks for your
help
you're welcome pam if you do you need
do you need help over there i mean in uh
in concord in
uh to get this um to get the
bills out i can certainly drive up to
concord it's just a 15-minute drive
no thanks for the offer um i think we're
we're set i mean there have been times
when people have been
largely remote but there are enough
people in the office
now you know all right added wrinkle
earlier
but um thank you
sure uh pam this is chris harbert yeah
um
i got the things squared away down here
for some reason everything in the
legislative email
my legislative email was marked as spam
so um i don't know who could have done
that
but uh it wasn't me no
well i'm pretty sure it was me but i was
probably
thought i was deleting something or
my daughter is here so she figured it
out in about 30 seconds
oh you've got tech support excellent so
so do you want to contin do you want
your invitations to come to your
legislative account or your personal
account
my personal account oh okay
just clogged up with stuff i don't want
to read all right
so so but you haven't been getting them
on your personal account because they've
been going to your personal account
no i've been forwarding i've been
getting them in the legislative
uh email and then forwarding to
my uh gmail account and that's how i
sign on
i've been talking about the zooms here
right me too but but until
today i've been sending them to your
personal account every single time
i don't know it was in the spam folder i
i don't understand this stuff so
yeah i don't either i you know believe
me i
i just um so i'll continue to
just continue to do it and uh
if it keeps going into spam i
don't know what to do well what you're
supposed to do is you're supposed to
a um make that email that's coming in as
as a a favorite you're supposed to like
actually put it cut and paste it into
your
customer or your contacts list so that
it's a contact that
it's a preferred contact so that is
supposed to uh one way
to stop to stop it from going into junk
mail
you can kind of make it up and you're in
your email
and then look at your junk mail account
your your rules
in junk mail and see what your rules are
um you might have your rules might be a
little too strict
because for instance if she's sending
him out bulk with multiple names on that
with that email then you're no
you do one each person yeah zoom just
you you set you you load all the
addresses
and names into zoom directly and it
sends them you know i don't it isn't
but it's not me you know me it doesn't
like whatever
it doesn't like whoever was sending it
like
like for a longest time because i have
you know my email address prodigy is
older than aol it's the
like the oldest out there so i was
having trouble with
the liquor commission they couldn't get
any of my emails i couldn't
couldn't get it and even when i was on
the board of new hampshire children's
health foundation
they they had to use my gmail account
they ended up having use of different
accounts i believe
because they that my prodigy was blocked
and that we
when actually i had the same problem at
the state house and that we figured out
was
actually the state house internet
provider
here in concord had was throwing anybody
i remember i thought was gone for a
while but now it's back
well now probably he's always been there
it's just it's just had multiple owners
i feel like a bank customer right
every couple of years i have a new new
name for my account
so right now it's now it's a t so i'm
i'm pretty safe that
we're not going to be shuffled again but
but they did drop my dial up i don't
have my dial up feature anymore
um which i never used it but the good
news is they then refunded me all the
money i was paying
that i was paying for for that feature
because i knew it was
i was paying it just to keep my email
address but turned out like you know
maybe i didn't need to do that or
whatever but
i mean this come the zoom invitations
come
addressed from hcs but
anyway it's yeah there's a there's
definitely a
some people there are issues and we've
we've tried to just use as many
addresses as people have and hope that
one of them gets through
right but i don't know what what happens
with representative mcaleer because
yeah hey chris are you there chris
michael are you there
or have you gone to get your coffee yeah
i might have stepped away because
he he comes in as an attendee and i
right he's keep hitting the wrong thing
coming in so i just want to know whether
because i noticed that
the new link we got today was at 7 57
right and so i just wanted to have him
go through his
his mail might see that that one at 757
and know that that's the one he needs to
click on to get in
right i'm sure he just uses the calendar
zoom address
right as a participant right which then
no as again as a
he's attendee as an attendee and then
you know i move him over
or or representative hunt moves him over
but right at
nine o'clock there's a lot going on and
i
you know there's i don't always see him
right right well you you and you picked
it up i didn't even
see him but
time
38.
john is that better perfect
okay so what i did i i went out and
i didn't sign back in under audio i just
did the picture
uh perfect that's right you turned the
music great
good and mr chairman just as long as i'm
sending the
the bills for next week to all the
democrats i might as well send them to
all the committee members since
everybody's
at home what do you think uh
it's all based on the request but uh if
you're if it's easy just to
do it for everybody i don't bother with
we're pony express out here so pam i
don't i don't need it either i can print
my own and
okay i just use i have a separate
computer right here so i just pull it up
on that
i don't need to be having anything
mailed to me either thank you though
okay yeah i just i hate to make it a
partisan thing
i'm not offended by that i i just
download everything electronically and
then i scribble my notes
okay perfect yeah we we know the
democrats really want to cut
trees and you know waste paper and
we understand one of the greatest sounds
wow whatever i used to joke about you
know cutting the trees gene chandler
remind me that that that was money
for the north country that they wanted
more paper
[Music]
they do grow back so you're
waving on having these paper things
mailed to you
yes oh okay i am
oh okay great thanks
i like the mail and apparently all my
email goes to spam anyway so
we've got to get through to you somehow
that's impossible well one thing i
one thing i did solve in terms of my
email type issues is that i
i do have a gmail account but i don't
tell anybody
it's it's you know sort of a secret
secret i keep it you know
i just assume not get too much stuff in
that account but
then every time one of these things come
up so pam
for a period of time was using my gmail
account but then then
the state house got solved my prodigy
problem
so that you might want to have that and
you know it came and i got it first
because i was a samsung android phone so
it made sense to have a gmail account so
and i don't do facebook that's the other
nice feature of the gmail is that
sometimes you can join an organization
get in with using the gmail account
as you log in rather than and then the
other one is facebook which i
i don't go near facebook i'm deathly
it's a blessing and a curse yeah well
[Laughter]
i'm sure good comes out of it i'm sure
some people i mean i i have a gmail
account let me have a facebook account
which i have to have because there's
sometimes right like restaurants you
can't get their menus you can't
you can't get anything unless it's on
paper so you have to be able to
get in but i whether anybody would ever
find my personality whatever find my
whatever it is that you find
on facebook yeah my profile so
because i'm i'm pretty sure there's no
picture
done
i wouldn't know i'm too afraid to go
check
i do as little of it as possible very
very little
it just seems like a big time sucker to
spend all that yeah every time people
post stuff and
it is a good way to get information out
to your constituents like about
vaccines and stuff oh yeah
oh definitely there's a lot of activity
that goes on facebook
you know that i probably don't see but
i go on just to check the um the kids
you know that's how i tell the kids
that's how your family members
um communicate with you is through
facebook
and we do have a town orange facebook
page
and uh because my wife is the president
of the rindge chamber of commerce she's
the one who you know like vaccines and
that kind of stuff
she posts he does all those posts so i
don't have to
do that and my wife because she's been
giving out shots she's been very active
in calling everybody and trying to get
people to get the vaccines
she's she's been a little crusader for
hey god bless her i got both of my shots
i'm done
right yeah i got my next tuesday
my second one all we got to get to is 70
that's it that's right
where are we at with the 70 how close
are we
[Music]
25 percent in the u.s have been
that that includes natural immunity too
so if you've had the virus
right okay i didn't realize that
but who's going to admit that they they
got it
all right we're getting close here so
let's see what we have kevin avar i'm
gonna move kevin up
[Music]
i'm the only one hearing that okay
9 45. good morning senator
evard oh my gosh i made it
you're in i'm in another committee right
now and uh
we were just having a panic attack
because i couldn't seem to log on to
this
site so cool okay
so hi everybody it's good to see you
nice smile we hear you we don't see you
but that's okay
that's probably not a bad thing uh i am
the author
of this bill uh it's a very simple bill
it basically
uh uh the bill basically it has to do
with
atc or alternative uh treatment centers
uh to organize businesses
corporations and limited liability
companies and provides the procedure for
alternative treatments
and is organized as a voluntary
corporation to convert businesses
or corporations uh or limited liability
companies
right now um the the atcs are operating
as a non-profit and this bill
is changes only one thing and it allows
them
to operate as a for-profit what we're
learning is that uh
because the uh they are they can't
benefit
uh as other corp uh non-uh
nonprofits by um there are
because it's the scheduled c drug and uh
there are some federal regulations that
go with that they're not able to benefit
as a non-profit and pass the savings on
to their patients so they're asking
that they can use the option to turn
into a
for-profit organization so that they can
pass the savings on to the patients
right now
if they're operating costs if they have
to take out a loan they can
uh generally be paying up to the 15
interest on those loans and so instead
of passing savings on to their customers
they have to pay off the loans or
capital investments that that they have
so this this really is a simple bill it
doesn't change anything with the laws it
doesn't legalize
marijuana across the board or anything
like that doesn't do anything drastic
it just allows them to operate as a
for-profit organization
allows them to lower their prices so
that the people that
that need the cannabis for medical you
can get it at a
a reduced rate rather than uh
the rates that they're charging right
now other states are doing that by
lowering interest rates with loans and
uh
but because they're a non-profit they
they can't do that here in new hampshire
so they're just asking uh to change
uh the language a little bit allowing
them specifically to
go into a for-profit status or llc it's
that simple nothing more complicated
we've had this bill before apparently
you did
yes uh and so hopefully it passes
musters this time it passed the senate
so so yeah what was the history so
let's have uh like i guess my memory is
i've never voted for it but
uh what was what was the history what
i was in here last year that's so uh i
think uh
it uh passed the house somebody's i
think it
this is another attempt maybe we changed
the language a little bit there were
some concerns about creating
senator french had a concern about it
becoming a monopoly so they amended it
so that it wouldn't
they couldn't become monopolies once
they went for-profit if you folks
uh decided to uh push this forward
yeah but the idea is that you're you're
going to get venture capital not
a bank loan because uh because banks
don't want a loan to it so you're going
to go out and try to get
venture capital and the question would
be is what happens if the venture
capital was rj reynolds
i've never heard of them i'm kidding
i'm kidding uh that question never came
up
i'm sure that there's uh there's some
folks that can
can talk to that specific because that
okay representative herbert uh thank you
uh chairman hunt and thank you uh
senator
um two questions basically uh are you
related to uh uh the school board member
uh avart here in manchester it all
depends
[Music]
just a curious question the other yeah
you are okay
good the other thing was um if i recall
the last time this bill came up
um and i could be uh totally wrong here
but um
the concern was that
besides the inability to
was the concern over
uh quality i think that because there
are some
organizations that are have a license
and specifically
right to provide a a very
pure high quality uh product
and um and so if somebody
uh you know venture capital or whatever
i came in
i think there was a little bit of
concern that there would be
these uh particular organizations that
specialized in making a medicinal
quality that's what this is this is
municipal these are the municipal
providers here in new hampshire well
that i guess that's what i'm saying is
back then i think the concern was that
somehow they might
uh get put out of business so i i just
don't know if uh that's a concern today
as it was then yeah this actually helps
them uh
in to survive as as an organization
according to them and it also
uh it changes nothing with the quality
or the licensures or
or the restrictions or the distribution
or anything of that nature
it really just changes a very simple
status from non-profit to for-profit
uh and there might be some venture
capitalists but i think that was one of
uh senator french's concerns uh and he
was concerned about monopolies and i
believe in the language
i can't show it to you right now i think
maybe michael mclaughlin
mr mclaughlin can uh can talk about that
uh
but uh that was one of senator's
french's concerns and he didn't want
that to happen
so i think we amended it in such a way
okay thank you so i guess that answer
uh representative weston's question so
we have uh representative bartlett
thank you mr chair um no just to go back
this was
um passed by our committee last term
and tabled um so that no that's
one of the histories this i think is the
third time we've heard this bill
um and it didn't have anything to do
with medicinal versus
for you know um legalization or anything
like this it was really a
simple bill about allowing um the
not-for-profit to become for-profit
mostly because of the cost of doing
business um so i don't really see a
problem
with passing this was already you know
would you believe it yes i would believe
that you're right
would you would you believe
representative
questions from the committee members uh
cena we thank you very much
thank you committee members i appreciate
your time okay
so next up i'm going to call mike
mclaughlin
who is
good morning mike
how's that perfect good morning uh mr
chairman and members of the committee my
name is michael mclaughlin i represent
sanctuary atc and i can do a quick um
review of what's happened in the past
senate bill 145
came to the from the senate in 2019
it passed the senate it moved to the
house where it passed the house on a
voice vote
the governor vetoed that bill uh on the
his
uh theory that somehow uh changing the
way they do business could lead to
industrial commercialization of
the marijuana industry
that reasoning we feel fails
in that the marijuana industry so-called
today's new hampshire therapeutic
cannabis uh distribution
centers are controlled by the state
the license or the registration that
they have to go through
is not a right that they can just apply
and get
it's a privilege offered by the state so
any
changes in the way that the so-called
marijuana industry operates
under the full control of the state so
when you look at senate bill 38
what senate bill 38 says is what we have
set up
is a structure that does not help
new hampshire citizens we did agree and
the governor agreed with his meth in his
veto message
the therapeutic cannabis program is good
for new hampshire
what has happened in the seven years
since the passage of the bill
is the department of health and human
services attract the
number of patients i think it's up to
ten thousand they've tracked the two
issues that they feel are important uh
the patients complain about two things
number one and two number one is price
and the price is affected by the fact
that as senator evard mentioned
atc's as not-for-profit corporations
get none of the benefits that a
not-for-profit corporation received
they cannot qualify as a 501c3 because
the internal revenue code and
federal law says it's a controlled drug
therefore they can't have that
as a not-for-profit you can't have an
equity investor nobody can invest in
not-for-profit
uh not-for-profits have to go for grants
contributions
and what we're left with is debt
the next cut of the federal issue is
federal banks federally chartered banks
will not loan
to companies that are in a business that
is where they control federal drug
therefore you have to go to
non-traditional commercial lenders
in order to capitalize the business what
senate bill 38 does
is it allows the conversion of a
not-for-profit
to a new hampshire for-profit
corporation there is
no benefit to the state
or to the patients in the not-for-profit
um
people will say well we set this up and
it should run as it's supposed to run
as it was formed to run but in the last
uh
several years we've had 19 bills that
made changes in the program
so changes in the mutation and the
maturation of a program
is natural and this is looked at as a
not-for-profit
uh situation this is something that's
not beneficial to new hampshire
again as senator avartz said there is no
change
to how this will be regulated how it
will be tested how it would be
advertised advertisement it isn't
because senate bill 38
senate bill 38 uh is exactly the same as
house bill
1345 from 2020 which passed the
committee and passed the house on voice
vote
it went to the senate and died on the
table so
the history of the bill is not negative
the only
bump in the road for uh conversion was
the governor's opinion
at that time that somehow
industrial commercialization would
happen now
representative mentioned moments ago or
somebody mentioned rj reynolds could
come in and
become an equity partner rj reynolds
could lend you
10 million dollars today and become a
controlling partner there
there's no there's no real connection
between how
a conglomerate would show up they
certainly could lend you money
now the again under uh
health and human services rules you
cannot
transfer the license so any time that
you get involved in this situation
the state controls there's no
opportunity
for uh rj reynolds or philip morris
or canadian mega marijuana to suddenly
appear in new hampshire and
take over the market we control the
market as it is today
and what senate bill 38 does is say
let's have a market
that works as efficiently as possible
for the people
and i'll happily answer any questions if
i can
but yes we've seen this bill several
times and it's always passed so i
urge you to look beyond the uh
the the hidden specter of here come the
big boys
and remember there's ten thousand people
out there including it's funny i was
looking the other day
twenty percent of those people are
represented by the members of the
commerce committee
so think about those people and think
about lowering the prices and a little
quick addendum
people near the border states mass
vermont and maine
are going across the border to buy
recreational marijuana to
satisfy their therapeutic needs which
undermines
the abilities of the new hampshire atc's
to continue servicing our patients
and again there was a monopoly issue
that somebody mentioned it's funny
when i looked at the the way the
registrations were handed out
they have to set up four distinct uh
territories much like utilities if you
had a free market therapy
therapeutic um cannabis world everybody
be down south in manchester or derry i
mean derry has
230 registered patients in 2019
manchester has 518.
so what they did is they said we're
going to allow it to happen but we need
to be able to service people in the
north country that's why we like playing
sanctuary is in plymouth and conway
so it is really uh there's
hard to find harm in this bill as i said
there's been 20 bills on 19 bills and it
made changes in conditions
in uh oversight it it's a it's a
constantly maturing process and we hope
that you'll see it that way
thank you thank you representative
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
mclaughlin for being here to take our
questions
you may not be able to answer this one
but it seems that you have an intimate
understanding of the bill so i'll try to
try to throw it your way
i'm looking at section three public
health of the bill
and parenthetical number four
um talks about board of managers as well
as board of directors i don't know if
that's a structural change
uh to the way things are run i i simply
don't understand why that's
as it is could you clarify that for me
please you have a term of
art and llc does not have board of
directors llc has a managing director
and the board of managers
so when you see that the some of the
much of the language in the bill
shows how you would convert to a
corporation or
how you would convert to an llc so for
instance i have an interest in llc
i'm a manager if my company was in
in quote it was incorporated i'd be on
the board of directors so it's just a
term of art
because the bill shows how you go from a
corporation or how you go to an llc
okay any other questions for mr
mclaughlin cnn thank you very much
representative edwards i apologize for
not calling you before
a lobbyist i i missed you and
no no sir you didn't you didn't miss me
i was uh chairing my committee
and i just now joined you so i
appreciate you recognizing me as quickly
as you have sir
okay perfect okay so uh my two minute
testimony on this
is that a government does a a few things
well
it does a lot of things not well one of
the things it doesn't do well
is it doesn't react to slow
environmental change it uh
and that is the case with our
alternative treatment centers i've been
looking at this
issue this is now my third term started
in hhs where we were hearing policy
bills regularly about
what kind of therapeutic diagnoses
uh were going to be permitted and the
like
and one thing that dawned on me pretty
quickly is that
we are way too involved in their
strategic management
and and uh and why is that really
critical at this juncture well
the environment around us as everyone
knows changed
we have recreational pot in all
directions
canada maine massachusetts vermont
so there is a new source of legal
regulated
weed that is a competitor to our
alternative treatment centers
and so if we want to
allow our alternative treatment centers
to survive
this new wave of competition uh where
people will just go back to
the self uh self treatment
and uh and forget uh the atc system that
we've established
um then then they they can do that
so i would encourage you uh to
consider this bill and recognize
that a more flexible adaptable
management style
is essential if these alternative
treatments or
centers are going to survive if you
don't want them to survive don't change
it
you know if you want them to survive
figure out the smart way to give them
management flexibility that that's what
this bill is looking to do and with that
surf uh there are questions i'd take
them
great thank you representative herbert
you're on mute
uh i just got finished with all the
thank yous but uh
the uh um the atc's
i i understand your reasoning and i
don't disagree with it
but what would distinguish after all is
said and done
the atcs from their competitors
in other words atc's now exist because
they have
some sort of a quality standard that
the recreational suppliers don't have
so is it your opinion that
the atcs will be able to compete on
price
but still maintain a distinguishing
uh advantage in terms of quality
so uh representative uh herbert herbert
or herbert i
i don't know if the age is sorry hey
bear herbert i'm fine
yeah english up here yeah french and
new orleans so so i've not met you and i
don't really know your background
and so pardon me if the answer is a
little longer than it should be because
i
i just don't know where i'm who where
i'm coming from on this other than to
say
that as a matter of state policy many
years ago
we made a decision that medical
cannabis was something that we wanted to
make available to new hampshire patients
and so we set up a process and a
procedure
where an individual would go to their
regular physician and um and then
if the physician thought therapeutic
cannabis fit within the diagnostic
procedures their diagnostic evaluation
that
of that patient he could or she could
refer
over to an alternative treatment center
the alternative treatment center
would then sit down with that patient
and
take a fresh look at the conditions
and would counsel that patient on the
types
of cannabis that could help them and i
think over half of the
cannabis medical cannabis prescriptions
are not smokable they
they they are tinctures and other
edibles
and so uh as you know recreational
marijuana maybe you know
maybe you don't but recreational
marijuana
is really thought of and is dominated by
smokables
and so the the the nature of what
a patient would consume through an
alternative treatment center
is likely to be different than if they
decided to self-medicate and go to a
recreational marijuana
store i they may have edibles too they
may have
tinctures too i i don't know i i haven't
been into one of our neighboring
uh uh pot centers but um
but so so what we offer
with our system is a kind of a medically
related patient-centric uh
uh system of care to where
they the patients receive palliative
treatments suitable for their needs and
palliative is distinguished from
um something that will solve a treatment
it's just palliative just means that
it's going to reduce the
adver or the symptoms somebody's having
of their disease condition
so so it's all medically regulated
and and and if we if those were to go
away
and we and we put people in a situation
where they had to self-medicate
then they would be less likely to
um obtain
the the the best cannabis
um does insurance play a role here at
all
uh in the sense that uh if you're doing
uh a medic
drug uh that you can
um have it insured
i think that's a great question and i
bet you there's actually someone on your
committee that would have a better
answer
i looked at it i've been looking at this
for years
from an hhs policy angle and not an
insurance angle
but i i i think the answer may be that
technically
this is not a medical prescription in
the sense that a
referring physician has done a
prescription and
ordered it this is uh
made available through medical cannabis
counseling and
maybe maybe if you had um one of those
health care savings accounts maybe
it would qualify under that i don't know
but i i would defer to the real answer
to
somebody on your committee thank you
you're muted uh chairman mr chairman
representative weston
thank you uh mr chairman and thank you
representative edwards for coming here
with your um
with the information you provided right
now we have four of these
atc's do you know if all of them are
doing enough business that they will be
able to continue
uh as an as a for-profit
uh facility and do you think that we may
actually be seeing
more once this change is made
those those are great questions and the
and the most direct answers
i don't know uh i i haven't been
uh into the uh into the weeds on this
uh but um to an earlier question
about you know what would what kind of
management changes
might take place in a more flexible
model
well in marketing you know you have the
four ps and
i'm going to be embarrassed if i can't
remember them but they're price
packaging product something else but
um but so uh we could see
the evolution of new service models you
know i
i've never understood why we
wouldn't allow the atcs to have
mobile uh dispensaries so that they can
go into the northern
parts of the country counties that don't
have access
easily and and provide a different level
of service
and and so that's the kind of thing that
i think
we could expect to see with more
management uh
flexibility and i generally believe
that that if you allow flexible
intelligent management
you're going to improve profitability
and so i that's not a direct answer to
your question
but but i think this bill would allow us
to have a more
flexible management style and therefore
tend to be more profitable and therefore
more likely to survive
thank you okay uh have no more hands we
thank you very much
and we'll let you get back to your
committee all right well thank you
yes good afternoon chairman and members
of the committee my name is ted rebholtz
i'm the president of the board of
directors for tennessee wellness
which is one of the alternative
treatment centers
we currently operate two of the licenses
in new hampshire we have a production
facility in manchester
dispensaries in dover and lebanon and
we're happy to say that we'll be
soon opening another dispensary in keene
we've served new hampshire patients
since the beginning having commenced
cultivation in manchester in january
and opening our first two dispensaries
in may of that year
and we not only operate our
brick-and-mortar stores we also make
all the products that we sell and quite
frankly if you look across the economy
there are not that many companies that
are as vertically integrated as we are
we are not allowed to ship cannabis
products across state lines
so as a result we have to replicate our
entire supply chain
at our manchester facility and those
operations are very capital intensive
most significantly we invest millions of
dollars into growing rooms that are
highly sanitary
and highly controlled for temperature
and humidity to optimize the safety of
our products for new hampshire patients
all of our products are tested for
safety and potency by an independent
new hampshire-based lab we support
this bill because it will enable us to
lower prices and to invest more
into education and product development
it will not alter
any of the regulations that ensure
safety for our patients
since the original medical cannabis law
in 2013 this legislature has on multiple
occasions adjusted the program to
benefit patients
and sb 38 presents another opportunity
to improve the program
for new hampshire patients as mentioned
by others today we are required to
operate as a nonprofit
but we do not get any of the benefits of
a non-profit
we do not have 501c3 status in fact
due to section 280e of the internal
revenue code we actually pay a much much
higher effective income tax rate
than other businesses further as also
mentioned we are simply not allowed to
borrow money from traditional banks
our only finance financing option for
the past six years
has been to borrow from private
individuals paying upwards of 18 to 20
interest that means about a third of our
revenue every single month
is soaked up by debt service passing
this bill
means reducing some of those onerous
barriers enabling us to lower prices for
patients
and to keep those patients and their
money in new hampshire
currently there's an aggressive and
targeted marketing campaign
by dispensaries in maine and those
caregivers are trying to entice new
hampshire patients to purchase cannabis
there
instead of from one of the designated
alternative treatment centers here in
new hampshire
there are regular persistent print and
radio advertisements especially in the
dover community
telling them that maine is the best
place for them to get affordable
cannabis
boasting that they are merely 20 minutes
away from downtown dover
and even offering to help them get a
card if they don't already have one
we've even had new hampshire patients
reporting that they received a discount
at the time of their purchase in maine
because
they're new hampshire patient so today
operators in maine and massachusetts are
both able to undercut our pricing
primarily due to this difference in
structure neither of those other states
requires cannabis businesses
to be non-profit massachusetts did
originally but
interestingly they have since eliminated
uh that requirement so today we have
patients reporting to us daily that
they're purchasing product in maine and
massachusetts solely
due to the lower prices we actually
conducted a survey of our patients
and one in three reported purchasing
cannabis out of state
and over 50 percent uh report that price
is the reason
they don't like this patients don't like
crossing state lines with cannabis
product it's actually a violation of
federal law
they also don't like spending their
money out of their home state of new
hampshire
they don't like having to question
whether the product they purchase in
maine has been tested
as it is here in new hampshire they also
don't like the lack of education
of the operators in the other states
don't take it seriously but at the end
of the day the bottom line is that
patients in new hampshire
are always concerned about affordability
and they're going to go
where they can actually afford it so
we're very grateful that the legislature
has made multiple improvements to the
original 2013 law
changing the corporate structure but not
changing any of the regulatory
requirements
is just one more of the changes that
needs to be made
to provide better access and
affordability
we pride ourselves on providing quality
cannabis for our patients and we
encourage you to pass this bill it is a
very modest change
that will allow us to lower prices for
patients again
while still maintaining the strict
regulations that will continue to ensure
patient health and safety
thank you um that was a wonderful
testament i hope you did post that
send that up listen put it on our web
page
um representative herbert uh
thank you chairman huh um thank you for
your testimony
uh mr rebels um
so i'm again i'm going to ask the
question in regards to
insurance uh and how that might work
uh because you're you are providing uh
amid uh you know a high quality
medicinal
um product uh which i it sounds to me
like a prescription
uh actually and uh and how that would
work
and and number two uh you have
vertically integrated your distribution
system
um which is expensive i'm sure
uh and uh with your various clinics
but it sounds to me as though
i who regulates you in terms of uh
uh your product quality i mean
the liquor commission for example uh
enforces liquor laws
right and and we have our own stores and
there's
good reason for that but uh
if you were going to compete and you get
to drop your price
which is i think necessary i
i'm not disagreeing with this this
legislation by the way
uh would it be
out of the a question that you would uh
could distribute through say the liquor
stores i mean i'm
i'm just throw that out there because
there's they're already there
and uh if somebody has a a card
and a prescription can go in and buy uh
your product
um and maybe that's not a good idea all
right because i'm
i mean i i no longer i don't smoke weed
anymore i think i started in 67
but i quit okay chris let's get to a
question my question is
two what what role if any does insurance
play
and and and the second question is
would you think or consider uh
distributing through
a liquor commission that's not your
representative herbert so in the answer
the first question
no there is no reimbursement
by health care insurers and that really
accentuates the point here
because new hampshire patients new
hampshire constituents
that price differential is that much
more acute if they get a bona fide
prescription
for lipitor for example their
out-of-pocket spend is going to be
close to or at zero because of the
healthcare reimbursement
none of that is applicable here in the
case of medical cannabis
so not only are the prices to new
hampshire patients higher than in other
states
there's no offsetting amounts from
health care insurance providers
to your second question um of course we
would not do that today because it's not
allowable
but our point of view is we want to
maximize access
for patients for those that have gone to
a provider
and in consultation with their provider
determined that medical cannabis is a
good alternative for them
we want to make it as easy as possible
for them to access their therapeutic
cannabis
um but again until there's a change in
the law allowing us to
sell our products at any locations other
than our own atcs
we will not be doing so
okay representative abel
yes thank you well thank you very much
for for testing
testifying um i really have two
questions so if i'll need to i may have
to ask them twice but
the first one deals with
what would happen if if this
bill did not go forward
and that's really the survivability
question
uh with
lower price competition across state
across
from other states and uh your
uh your difficulty in getting financing
and so forth
is there a possibility that uh
some of the providers now would
would end up going out of business is
that is that possible
i think it is unlikely um this is a
business i mean
you have it's it's tough to tell because
you have offsetting factors
right uh on the plus side in new
hampshire
you have a growing awareness of
therapeutic cannabis
as a potential alternative for patients
and as we've seen the number of patients
registered in the program
has continued to grow year over year
however
even if you have new patients enrolled
in the program
it's it's not necessarily the case that
all of them are purchasing in new
hampshire
and as is the case with a lot of our
patients they purchase in maine
but they still come to us so they might
buy 90
of their product needs in maine at the
lower price
they still come to us for that other 10
percent because they're getting 90
of the good education they're getting 90
of the good advice
from a strictly regulated therapeutic
cannabis program that we have here
in new hampshire so i think we're going
to continue to see
the the new hampshire program um
basically just trudge along
so i'm not concerned about the
survivability
but i am concerned about our ability to
continue to innovate
continue to serve patients and to reduce
prices
right now the prices that we're able to
offer are artificially inflated
because of this restriction on our
okay thank you thank you may i
ask one further question i'm sorry okay
thank you uh well the the second
question was price
and i i can certainly see uh the reason
uh the uh rationale for believing
that you could lower prices if if your
cost of doing business were lower
but that also becomes a matter of uh
our taking it on faith uh is that are
there
any other states where something
comparable to this
has happened where non-profit
nonprofit providers have been have been
able to become
uh for-profits and that there has been a
reduction in price or do we just take it
on faith
that that would happen so
massachusetts is is a good example of
a state that like new hampshire
originally required
licensees to be non-profits however they
made the machi
they made the change so long ago it was
so early in the development of their
marketplace that i
i don't really think it's it's
comparable um
and i don't i'm not aware of anybody
that's looked at the potential price
impacts uh of that statutory change
what i can say from an operator's point
of view
who wants to be successful in the new
hampshire
therapeutic cannabis program there's a
lot of demand for cannabis
there is a lot of demand it's growing
and awareness is growing
but people are going to look for the
easiest way
to fulfill those needs and increasingly
they're recognizing that driving an
extra 20 minutes an extra 30 minutes
to cross one of the state lines and as
we know you know wherever you are in new
hampshire you're not too far away from a
state line
you can get over uh and avail yourselves
uh of much lower prices
so from my point of view it's a business
imperative
to meet consumers where they are and
right now where they are is
traveling out of state to avail
themselves of lower prices
so if i want to compete if i want us to
be able to continue to innovate and
serve new hampshire patients
and hopefully a growing number of new
hampshire patients i have no option
okay any other questions
um i i have one other question um your
the company did your your work work for
what is it called
tennessee wellness chemist called
wellness
are you in other states we are we're in
massachusetts as well
just just massachusetts uh we were
formerly in maryland
and we're no longer operating there oh
okay
um and so uh in massachusetts are you
operating as a do you sell it to the
general public because
massachusetts marijuana is legal so are
you selling to the general public in
massachusetts
yes we serve both medical patients as
well as recreational adult use customers
right so in that case you don't need a a
card
to get marijuana that's correct you need
government issue photo id to prove that
you're of
of age but you don't need a
certification from a health care
provider
okay great great thank you very much um
okay so i have gone through all the
people who signed up
um oh i have an attendee who
just raised their hand
a heather okay so uh i'll
invite heather to testify
and tell us who you are other than just
heather
you have to oh sorry about that yep no
problem technology is not my friend
sometimes
um my name is heather marie brown and i
am a certified cannabis patient
within the state of new hampshire
i appreciate the work that you guys have
put into this
but i am speaking in opposition
of this bill i do not feel that our
dispensaries should be allowed
to go from non-profit to profit bearing
and the reason behind that is and the
gentleman that spoke to
before he had a lot of wonderful
information but it was a little
one-sided
um i believe that if you do this
then you open up the opportunity of
what we call in the cannabis world big
canna
coming into new hampshire and getting
their fingers
i have seen in other states
where non-profits have
started selling in a profit-sharing way
because of recreation becoming legal or
whatever
and then watching their medical programs
slowly
dissolve
i don't think that that's what we need
in new hampshire
i think that if dispensaries are
concerned
with being able to lower their pricing
for the consumer which by all rights
they should be because i can
tell you that new hampshire dispensaries
are not my first choice of preference
when i need to get my meds because of
the limited income that i have
i think that if dispensaries want to be
able to reduce
their costs enough to be able to pass
that savings on to the consumer
then we need to look at the program at
the state
level we need to pick apart the program
and look at all of the areas and the
restrictions
and the requirements that the state has
put on
the dispensaries as far as operating
goes
which places a huge increase
in the costs and their expenses which
therefore
they have to pass that cost
and that increase on to the consumer
even just to be able to break even to
continue forward
we already do have a problem
with our dispensaries as far as growing
for quantity
versus quality and i don't necessarily
mean that in a harsh negative or
insulting way
i'm just saying that yes there is a
demand
on our dispensaries in the state i i
i'm saying that in order for these
dispensaries
to meet this demand they have to grow
more and keep up on their quantity and
sometimes
quality can lessen because of it
if they want to be able to save money
then the state needs to take a look at
how they are treating these dispensaries
and the requirements and the
restrictions that they are putting on
these dispensaries
that's where it needs to start we all
know that at some point in time in new
hampshire
recreational cannabis will be made
available to the public
it's not a question about when it's
coming
it we know it's coming you know it could
be tomorrow it could be in two years
it's still coming if those dispensaries
are allowed to go from non-profit to
profit bearing
then who's to say when legalization
finally hits
new hampshire that they're going to be
able to
a be able to produce enough cannabis
to supply both the medicinal and the
recreational market and b keep up with
the quality that's in place
you know we all want the cannabis to be
lowered in new hampshire but
the majority of patients will tell you
they want the cannabis to
they want this to be new hampshire
cannabis
they do not want out of state interests
to be able
to come into new hampshire and work with
our dispensaries
if they change to non and if they change
from non-profit to profit status
um i think that that's a huge thing
we've already seen problems come from
big pharma
getting into new hampshire why would we
want the same thing to happen with
cannabis
you know we as a state we have so much
pride in being the first in the nation
for this and the first in the nation for
that well how about we be a first in the
nation as far as cannabis goes
as well and keep it locked down
so that this is a a new hampshire
available product controlled by
new hampshire interests you know why not
take a look at the state level to be
able to re
reduce the costs the requirements and
the restrictions
that are put on these dispensaries so
that they can take
and pass those savings on to the
the community to the patients that they
serve and represent
you know i support my dispa all four of
these dispensaries i actually
am a um i am the patient representative
on the new hampshire therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board
and this is something i'm constantly
saying at our meetings you know
if we're going to do something to fix
the medical program then we need to take
a look at what's going on at the state
level first
before we continue passing some of these
bills
that could potentially put new hampshire
cannabis
at threat for the future
great thank you very much for your
testimony um we do have a couple of
questions if you're willing to entertain
them
i most certainly am representative
burroughs you may go ahead
thank you for taking my question um
which is that there's been a lot of
testimony today that
stated that um if the if the business if
this business could be grown
and the revenue could be grown that the
prices would would go down for consumers
so my question is do who do you think
would be better
um has more ability to
to work in the what am i trying to say
do you think that an
entrepreneurial company would be better
suited to grow that revenue and to grow
the company
than would a non-profit that that is not
focused
is normally not focused on business
activities
i personally believe that
like i said if i i think that the
restrictions and requirements at the
state level
will play a major impact in this
regardless
of where or how
the company chooses to proceed whether
they're
non-profit they're still going to be
held to those restrictions
if they turn to a for-profit i mean at
that point in time growing revenue is
important
yes but the restrictions won't
necessarily
be put into place that are in place
as far as it being a non-profit run
organization and therefore i do foresee
yes there may be extra revenue and
savings that could be passed on
but i also foresee a problem
continuing on the downhill slide
as far as quantity and quality goes
which in that case would still continue
to push
new hampshire residents to seek
ulterior sources for
their cannabis because at the end of the
day
it's the quality of the cannabis that
actually lends in
to the medicinal treatment that i
that myself and the other 9 000 and some
odd patients in the state of new
hampshire are looking for
thank you okay representative bartlett
thanks very much mr chair um so
let me get this right you um
thank you for coming before our
committee and and giving us your view
so you purchase your marijuana out of
state
you're on the oversight board but you
still don't want the free market
to control the pricing is that correct
i do not want out of state interest to
be able to get into new hampshire
cannabis
i have seen many of these companies
go into other states and the cannabis
programs have been
almost obliviated like currently in
massachusetts in order to
purchase a eighth of cannabis
you're you're looking at approximately
between
70 and 85 dollars
for an eighth of cannabis now up here in
new hampshire right now
it isn't that expensive but it's pretty
darn close to it
and you know everyone assumed that when
legalization came through in
massachusetts
that prices would ultimately go down
and that is not the case prices
ultimately ended up
going up and the quality continued to go
down
so in massachusetts they are having a
very large issue right now because the
black market
is alive and thriving and will continue
to do so
because of the high costs associated
with cannabis
and those black market agents
they are able to produce a more craft
cannabis
product which contains the quality that
medical
may ask one more question yes okay we're
getting a little tight on time here but
okay that's okay i'll i'll
forgo let anybody anybody else okay uh
representing
uh yes thank you mr chairman um heather
you said that
uh legalized marijuana in new hampshire
is most likely gonna happen we just
don't know when
if that happened and we declined this
bill
um i don't necessarily um believe that
i believe that there
i believe that this bill could
potentially
have some positive impacts but i do
believe that changes
need to be made to the bill in order to
not allow the outside interests
to be able to come into new hampshire
that's where i believe
the problems will lie is when you have
the outside
interest coming into the state because
those individuals don't necessarily
have the compassion and the devotion
to taking care of new hampshire patients
has what an
individual born and bred and raised in
okay uh representative greeson
thank you mr chairman and thank you
heather for your uh testimony but uh
the question i have you keep mentioning
uh
regulations at the state level that if
we could remove those restrictions or
whatever
do you have any idea of what those
restrictions might be that you'd like to
see
removed that would produce the results
that you're looking for
and encourage you yourself to begin
purchasing here in the state
when a dispensary needs to
get rid of whether it's their stocks
or you know the the leftover
the the leftover debris after processing
the state has many restrictions on how
that needs to be disposed of
involving taking that material
mixing it in with i believe at least 50
a minimum of 50 percent sawdust which
that sawdust needs to be purchased by
the company
then it needs to be double and triple
bagged then it needs to be
put into a special waste disposal unit
then it needs then there needs to be a
special company
that's hired to come and pick up such
debris and material
all of that adds extra expense when in
reality
those products that the leftover debris
contain
absolutely no thc they are of no danger
to the public
and could be disposed of in a much
better manner such as
allowing the facility to use it for
composting
or allowing the facility to sell it
to a registered composter
in the state of new hampshire that could
then legally take that material
and dispose of it and use it to go into
composting materials
that in itself would not only cut down
on
costs for the dispensary but could also
offer a little bit of extra
income as well um i also know
that in the area of security
there are you know obviously security is
a necessity we need to have that in
place
but i think that to an extent some of
the kids
the security measures that we and
requirements that we have for our
dispensary
may be a tiny bit of overkill
and there may be in essence creating a
redundancy in the system
that doesn't necessarily need to occur
being able to change that in some
fashion would cut down
on an expense for the dispensary because
i don't know if you've ever looked into
any of those um
security programs or products but
you know we're talking tens and
thousands of dollars
just for a dispensary to be able to
utilize and access that
um you know if we could change that up a
little bit and
you know have them put in place a
security system that works that covers
it from
seed to and still gets the job done
efficiently and safely then that would
be
another way to cut costs down for the
dispensaries
so there are several areas that could be
looked at
that would cut down costs at the state
level for a dispensary
and allow a dispensary in some instance
to
save money or even bring in a little
extra money from outside of the
dispensary
that ultimately could be passed on in
thank you mr chair thank you for your
testimony taking our questions heather
i just have a question about um this
situation in massachusetts like
we know that our marketplace in our
state
is uh determined somewhat by surrounding
states
but you had mentioned that i think you
said an eighth of cannabis is 70 to 80
dollars in massachusetts
and you said the black market is alive
and thriving
because of that high cost and my
question is do you know how much
uh the state of massachusetts taxes
that amount how much of that seventy
eight or dollar eighty dollars is
taxed by the state versus uh you know
charged by the
producer um i honestly
i i would be putting a guesstimate but
at the la
at my last check i believe
okay it could possibly be more at this
point but originally i believe
it was about fifteen dollars on the cost
and which still does not bring it down
in comparison to
what you can get it here in new
hampshire but then again they still have
restrictions
in place that you know cause them to
still have to put more money out than
what they necessarily have to
so and obviously that affects the cost
okay thank you okay all set
all right um so uh mike
i see that you have your hand up um my
preference would be
that you would send
uh just send an email out to all the
members
but um if you're the model of brevity
and expenses and i'll let you have the
last word
thank you mr chairman i'll be very quick
i just wanted to point out that one of
the things that the
three atc's do is provide discounts
for uh people on disability income
medicaid and for veterans
and in our in 2019 century put four
hundred and two thousand dollars worth
of discounts
available to the public uh and one of
the things that it's just uh
important to remember this bill uh is
a short window for conversion conversion
would have to happen
they are participating heavily in trying
okay sounds like you're getting in your
car you're on your way so with that we
will
end the public hearing um and
uh let's see i have uh
18 in support and
uh no one was opposed until until
today we had heather and with that i
will close the public hearing on senate
bill
38 and next up is
senate bill uh 59
and um so with the uh
senator who's the sponsor when you raise
their hand so i can
who is the sponsor okay representative
hello mr chair it seems like just
yesterday i was with you all
uh it's great to be back uh
for the record my name is uh senator tom
sherman
district 24 11 towns on the seacoast i'm
introducing senate bill 59
which is relative to the collaborative
care model service delivery method
for full disclosure there will be some
experts who will be testifying and
able to answer from the psychiatrist's
standpoint
why this bill is so important but a
brief
overview is that as most of us know
there is a mental health crisis
currently in the state part of that
and what collaborative care
does is it allows a patient to go
into their primary care provider who
then has a collaborative care
relationship with a psychiatrist
and essentially the primary care
provider
taps into the expertise and knowledge
and experience
of the psychiatrist in a formal
way it is a
basically a consultation
the patient does not have to go and see
the psychiatrist the primary care or the
provider will actually
have that interaction and then the
psychiatrist will be able to help guide
the therapy
along with the primary care provider
this is super important because we as a
state
have been working towards what's called
an integrated delivery
network model as many
uh in the committee know we have had a
federal grant
to make this happen across the state
and it really is the standard of
practice for psychiatry and for
behavioral health to be able to provide
that point of service delivery we also
know
when comes back to workforce that there
is some limitation on the availability
of
psychiatrists and what the
collaborative care model does is it
vastly expands that availability
uh of psychiatry across the state
without sacrificing um the quality in
fact
it in many ways it enhances quality
and so from the patient benefit
it is essentially one-stop shopping they
come into their primary care and they're
able within the limits of the primary
care model
to be able to access their
psychiatric services at the same time
it is associated in studies with better
outcomes better accessibility
and it's a better use of resources it's
more
efficient overall
one of the benefits for this is overall
decreased
cost of services if the psychiatrist
feels that the patient does need to be
seen
separately and individually of course
that is possible and that can be part of
this is something that we have worked
with the carriers on
very closely we worked with the medical
society
with the psychiatric society
the carriers helped craft the language
that you see
before you worked closely with paula
and anthem as well as harvard pilgrim to
to do certain things the original bill
as introduced back in 2019
had actual codes in it we pulled those
out and talked about the scope of
service
rather than putting in specific codes
that was at the request of the carriers
and then we modified language further
with paula's help
to what you currently see the department
of insurance
working with tyler is neutral on this
they're not taking a position
but this is uh to
ensure that that this practice is
allowed reimbursed and
is and that's across all carriers
so with that and with the understanding
that there are
experts who are available to
answer some of the specifics of
psychiatry
i would only add that in my practice of
gastroenterology
we know that this kind of collaborative
care model
is most effective especially for the
more difficult patients with
problems like irritable bowel syndrome
and those
and in my practice
having this capacity would have been
game changing for those patients what we
do currently is we do it informally
but that means that we don't have as
much support as
would be optimal and so this
in the field of psychiatry is really
the standard of practice and we want to
be sure that it is available across the
state
thank you i'm happy to take any
questions
and she's muted
sorry about that um thank you for taking
my question senator
um just from what i see of the
healthcare profession
primary care providers are not super
knowledgeable about nutrition and about
um psychiatric disorders or mental
health issues so
i'm cure just curious and this sounds
like a great bill but my question is
how will a primary care physician
buy the the treatment of a of a patient
um in this scenario in the collaborative
model i know you mentioned that
that they'll will be helped by the
psychiatric uh um
professional but i'm i'm just a little
little confused about how that would
actually work in practice
yeah actually um i i have not seen the
sign up list is dr ho
on your signup list yep can i defer
to him he is a practicing psychiatrist
and
he could i can share with you the model
that if you walk into our primary care
providers at core
they actually now working through the
idea and they have
access to psychiatry services what this
would allow
say dr buchanan or one of our primary
care doctors to do would be to call up
dr
ho and and actually have a formal
consultation where
she would present the patient to dr ho
has depression and here are the
manifestations of that
here's the other medical history they
could exchange the history
dr ho then creates a chart on that
patient
and working together dr ho would give
his psychiatric opinion what would be
the best medications
how to follow up and they would continue
to work collaboratively
with that patient's care so
that is but the patient themselves would
not have to go to another office would
not have to spend another
hour or so with dr ho unless
in that review dr ho and dr buchanan
feel that they need a separate referral
for formal psychiatric consultation
does that help answer the for the
question
being clear yeah no that was a great
answer thank you so much so
it sounds like let's say a patient is
seeking
medication for a psychiatric or mental
health disorder
that the psychiatrist could recommend a
specific
medication which the primary care
physician could then um write a script
for
would that be accurate yes that would be
accurate and
the other part of this i you know i'm
sorry i don't know your background but
we have had for many years in in my
field i'll get a call from a primary
care provider with somebody with
diarrhea and i will talk about it's
called a curbside consult
but i don't keep a formal record the
beauty of this
is that that formal record would be kept
by that provider by the psychiatrist
it would be something that the patient
could access if they need to
get a copy of their medical record so
this is a formal relationship
which is uh all the data shows that that
is
a much more effective relationship in
healthcare than
than the curbside consult that has been
so i hope that helps thank you that's
really helpful thanks
okay uh so the chair will now call on
patrick ho
thank you mr chair thank you
and can everybody hear me yes we can
excellent thank you mr chairman and
members of the committee for allowing me
to speak today for the record
my name is patrick ho and my testimony
today is on behalf of both the new
hampshire psychiatric society which i
serve as the president and the new
hampshire medical society
of which i am an executive committee
member in these capacities
we fully support senate bill 59 as a
strong effort to improve our ability to
deliver mental health care in new
hampshire
and personally as a psychiatrist then i
support this bill because
i feel the frustrations of patients who
come to
an ed or seek inpatient mental health
care seeing no other option amidst the
severe shortage of psychiatrists and
other mental health practitioners in our
state
so i i will keep my testimony brief and
we'll just briefly provide some
additional overall context
in addition to what senator sherman had
just
outlined really well for collaborative
care model services
and of course one of the things to
mention is that although new hampshire
has the highest proportion of citizens
suffering from mental health disorders
out of any state
nearly a quarter of these citizens do
feel that their mental health care needs
are
unmet and this is in in part like dr uh
like dr sherman had mentioned due to a
shortage of psychiatrists
and um to provide a little bit more
context about collaborative care model
services
then this is definitely a feature that
can bridge the gap with better care
coordination via integration of mental
health
and primary care so this is truly
collaborative
in that there is a team approach
consisting of a primary care provider a
care manager
and a psychiatric consultant which
ideally would be an md or do
psychiatrist
the team cares for a defined group of
patients within the primary care
practice and closely tracks each
patient's progress
and so in that way then instead of a
psychiatrist seeing
one patient individually that the
psychiatrist is able to
help the primary care provider care for
an entire panel of patients
treatment is adjusted if patients are
not improving as expected
patients who don't respond to treatment
are referred to more intensive mental
health specialty care
including seeing the psychiatrist
instead of psychiatrists seeing all
patients one-on-one the
the psychiatrist provide caseload
consultation
to a population of patients for the
primary care practice providing
proactive and effective mental health
care this approach of course would
improve access
health outcomes and reduce provider
burnout for both
the primary care physicians on the front
lines of
of illness in our state both physical
and mental and of course the the
psychiatrist
medicare and federally qualified health
centers and rural health clinics already
do allow reimbursement for collaborative
care model services
and this legislation would allow for
primary care providers to build
commercial insurers for the model which
would safely increase
access to mental health care so finally
with the added
stressors of coven 19 the need for
mental health care services
is higher than ever and this makes the
lack of access to these services even
more pronounced
and strains other healthcare resources
like emergency departments
we've of course seen in just the last
month with so many children
and adults waiting for inpatient
psychiatric beds that this has become
untenable so it is really now more
important than ever that we allow for
the use of evidence-based practices to
increase the availability of mental
health
services in our state so i urge you to
vote in favor of senate bill 59 and i'm
certainly glad to take any questions
thank you great thank you
uh representative has the question thank
you mr chair and thank you for
your testimony you had mentioned that uh
i believe you said new hampshire has the
highest percentage of citizens
suffering from mental health disorders
of any state
and i was curious if you had a source
for that that's kind of an interesting
statistic
yes thank you for uh thank you for the
question um and
when i send in my um my written
testimony then i can certainly also send
in the source for that as well great
thank you thank you
all right no other questions uh mr ho
doctor ho
thank you very much uh chair will now
chairman and members of the committee um
my name is ken norton i'm the executive
director of nami new hampshire the
national alliance on mental illness
i'm a licensed independent clinical
social worker in new hampshire and i've
served as
subject matter expert in the areas of
mental health as well as suicide
prevention for the
u.s substance abuse and mental health
services administration the department
of defense the veterans administration
and it served on a number of commissions
and committees in new hampshire as well
and on behalf of nami new hampshire our
mission is
we're not treatment providers per se but
our mission is to improve the lives of
all people impacted by mental illness
we strongly support senate bill 59
and the collaborative care model as
you've heard
governor sununu has repeatedly stated
including
last month that we're in a mental health
crisis and one thing is clear about that
crisis and that's that
we will not be able to resolve this
crisis if we continue to do business as
usual
so we need to come up with um with new
and better ways of
improving the service delivery model and
it's it's well documented that people
with mental illness have long faced
discriminatory practices relative to
health insurance coverage
um by comparison to other disease states
but this is um
a model that um that lack of parity
continues today the new hampshire
insurance department
has a mental health and addiction
advisory council that's worked for
several years and this is the type of
model that
um that has come out of some of those
conversations
it's really a hold over from the days of
asylums that we treat people with mental
illness in a segregated model of
care where their mental health
conditions are
and substance abuse or addiction are
treated separately from their overall
care as a person
and we certainly know that there's a
significant amount of research and
evidence
showing improved outcomes for patients
when their care is integrated and that's
both for their mental health treatment
as well as for serious medical
conditions like diabetes cancer
and heart disease where there's a
frequency of co-occurrence
um with mental illness as you've heard
there's a significant shortage of
psychiatrists nationwide
especially child psychiatrists and new
hampshire
certainly experiences that and so
towards that end this
the psychiatric collaborative care model
can be very effective
one of the things that i would mention
that's that's key in there
is in addition to the care directed by
the team and the care management is
regular assessments of clinical status
using validated tools and i would
particularly note that
one of those tools that we're now
starting to see more regularly used by
primary care providers is a life-saving
tool and that's screening for suicide
suicide's the second leading cause of
death in new hampshire in our state
and and oftentimes primary care
providers are
have avoided using those screening tools
because they really don't know how to
respond if the person
answers in the infer in the affirmative
so having a psychiatric collaborative
care model where they can review
what's happening with a psychiatrist
what the symptoms are
what some of the other characteristics
of that individual are
can be really helpful in helping to
reduce the public health
issue that we face relative to suicide
prevention
um it's pretty clear as well and has
been mentioned that the long run
improved outcomes will likely
result in overall health and care cost
savings as well
um and so i'd like to thank senator
sherman for sponsoring this important
bill
it's clearly the direction that health
care needs to move in
and on behalf of nami new hampshire i
strongly urge you to vote
um sb 59 is on to pass
great thank you uh any other questions
any questions from the committee members
for dr norton uh
[Music]
oh there's a hand up
okay representative emma thank you mr
sharon thank you for your testimony
uh you don't have a question about um
[Music]
consent by the patient so let's say
someone comes in
and they seem kind of mopey and
depressed
does the patient know that their primary
care physician
might be contacting a psychiatrist is
that done with
patient consent or could that be
happening without consent
um it would be done with patient consent
and i i can't answer that specifically
because i'm not
um we're not treatment providers dr ho
might be able to
answer that um more effectively but dr
sherman mentioned the integrated
delivery networks that we've developed
in new hampshire
an agreement between the patient and the
and the provider that in certain
circumstances information
would be shared so um but yes that's a
great question because it's really
important and
ethically speaking it would be a
requirement
for some informed consent from the
patient relative to that
thank you mr chair thank you take for
taking my question
um where do you see um or the question
would be
um could you see a naturopath
um being part of this integrated
delivery network in the future because i
think
thank you for your question um i can't
speak to that specifically
for this bill because it's not to my
knowledge part of that
the the psychiatric collaborative care
model
but i would certainly say from nami new
hampshire's perspective that we believe
that there's many
paths to successful recovery and
treatment
and and naturopathy would be one of
those and we would hope that you know
that that's
a consideration for people in terms of
alternatives to treatment
thank you okay
great thank you very much uh chair will
now
call in sabrina dunlap who represents
anthem and is neutral on this bill
hi thank you representative hunt and
members of the committee my name is
sabrina dunlap and i'm director of
government relations at anthem
as senator sherman said this bill was
around last year and my colleague paula
rogers was able to work
with senator sherman and providers and
others to get the amendment to a place
we're more comfortable with
so anthem does support the amendment um
i do just want to point out that anthem
already covers
the collaborative care model addressed
in the bill and
we've been ready to reimburse for this
for a while
uh the issue is utilization and for some
reason providers just not
using uh this very often um
and my understanding from senator
sherman is that the hope is the
legislation one
will encourage more use um by providers
of the model but i did just want to flag
that that we do already cover this
um so anyway uh we want to thank senator
sherman and others
for working on the amendment and um
thank you and i'm happy to take any
questions
so do you know of of the other companies
whether they also offer it or i know
this is kind of an awkward question for
you
but does harvard cover this also
i'm not 100 sure i would be surprised if
other carriers did not also cover this
model
okay so the issue is the reason we're
putting this in
is it's just you will say to get more
people to try to take advantage of it
because it's there in the statute that
is my understanding
okay representative abramson has a
question
thank you mr chair uh are you able to
hear me through the mic
yes we are okay uh my
my question is my reading of the of this
bill is is
it does look like a state mandate
okay um sorry is the question whether
it's a mandate
yeah yes whether it's a mandate under
rsa415
so i'm probably not the best person to
answer that i i assume
someone from the new hampshire insurance
department will be speaking to this um
i would yeah i would leave it there and
defer to them
okay okay uh tyler had
tyler did not sign up to speak but i'm
sure he could uh help out there
uh well there's not a there's not a
fiscal note on this and there's not a
there's not a business impact in the
bills
i'm wondering what the net effect is
going to be on
insurance
uh we can we can uh we generally we
don't
when a a health insurance mandate it's
hard to quantify
we do have a process in which we can
have the department
do an economic review and see if what
the
the impact of a mandate is but
we don't it is true it might not show up
on anything
in terms of the bill or certainly in the
all set okay uh and we have no more
questions
we thank you very much okay now
we'll be back so i now have i
have uh jake barry
and let me find find you jake if you
want to raise your hand and i can
oh and there's peter bragdon is here so
he can tell us about harvard
okay good morning mr chair honorable
members of the committee my name is jake
berry i'm the vice president of policy
of new futures
as many of you know new futures is a
non-partisan nonprofit
health policy and advocacy organization
we've been working for more than 20
years to address behavioral health
issues
in our state i don't repeat too much of
what's been
said this morning uh certainly it's been
covered well but i do want to emphasize
new future strong support for this bill
i know i don't need to tell you about
the deep toll that new hampshire's
ongoing mental health and addiction
crises are having on our state and we
feel the
covenant we fear the token 19 pandemic
will only further exacerbate these
issues
under coca 19 more than 30 percent of
granite staters are reporting symptoms
of anxiety and depression and other
mental health concerns according to data
from the kaiser family foundation
and of those nearly 20 percent reported
unmet needs for counseling and therapy
uh care coordination has not long been
seen as a
as critical to helping our state
overcome the ongoing behavioral health
crises
by supporting the collaborative care
model sb 59 would go far to enhance care
coordination
across our state and to extend
behavioral health services for those in
need
uh as we've discussed today
collaborative care has been shown to
eliminate barriers to care
improve clinical outcomes and reduce
treatment costs for many behavioral
health conditions
this bill will help to maximize these
positive impacts and help us to overcome
the ongoing behavioral health crisis so
with that we ask you to vote out to pass
and i'm happy to take questions
great uh any questions from the
committee members
uh i do not see any so thank you very
much
thank you okay uh peter ragnan
for representing harvard uh thank you mr
chairman i hope you can all hear me
uh i'll bring you into this but that's
all right um
uh for the record peter bragdon
representing harvard pilgrim healthcare
and uh like anthem we're we're neutral
on the bill uh we're supportive
certainly of the collaborative care
model and all the benefits that senator
sherman
uh mentioned and like anthem these are
things that
we do and would cover um and i think the
the big problem as sabrina said is just
the utilization and perhaps because
people don't know what's available so
uh i wasn't going to testify since we're
neutral but uh since the question was
asked i thought i would provide an
answer
appreciate it very much and i assume
that's all
it needs from you so thank you very much
okay
so i have one more person signed up
charles
brackett
and i'm promoting you up trolls
and i see you with hitchcock are you a
doctor bracket
yes hi i am charles brackett i'm a
primary care physician at
dartmouth-hitchcock and part of a team
that's implemented
implementing the collaborative care
model of behavioral health integration
into the primary care clinics of our
system
um so we've heard about the crisis
situation and
that there aren't enough psychiatrists
to go around but in addition to this
lack of psychiatrists stigma and
negotiating a complex system
are also barriers to behavioral health
care
and integrating behavioral health into
primary care can help
address these barriers by mainstreaming
it making it more
kind of a usual
part of medical practice
and i just would clarify that the
collaborative care model is a specific
model of health behavioral health
integration it is not a co-located model
the um the care manager we call them the
behavioral health clinician
doesn't just manage care they actually
do counseling that supports the primary
cares interventions
uh pharmacologically and otherwise and
and then the behavioral health clinician
is supervised by the psychiatrist so
usually the
psychiatric input is kind of indirect um
but the psychiatrist is also available
for consultations
uh so the impact study of the
collaborative care model
uh demonstrated that one dollar spent on
collaborative care saves six dollars and
fifty cents
in overall health costs because it
reduces costs for physical conditions
and reduces admissions and ed visits
and in a fee-for-service environment
these savings go to insurers while many
of the expenses of the collaborative
care model are not covered
and are worn by the clinic most insurers
have actually recognized this
and all of the insurers that we looked
into in new hampshire
are actually already covering these
codes but i think it's important to
to make it a requirement to prevent uh
backsliding
um so medicare added these these codes
in january 2017 to cover these expenses
but they've not been widely used as was
mentioned
because they're very complex to uh
to track the time there's time
requirements and other documentation
that have to happen in a calendar month
so we're three months
into our implementation and have not yet
built for these codes but we're working
towards that goal
and we're hoping if we can effectively
bill for these codes and cover our costs
we can expand
uh our model and better meet the
behavioral health
needs of the population so it's not
practical or ethical for us to
treat patients differently based on
their insurance so it's critical that
these billing codes
are covered by all payers going forward
and i urge you to vote in favor of this
bill and i'm happy to take questions
see none we're all thank you thank you
dr brackett
okay that's all the people i had signed
up
is anybody else would like to speak uh
okay i don't see any more hands going up
so i think we're good
um we had a 119 people in support
one opposed not sure where that post
person
[Music]
so otherwise uh
i will close the public hearing on
senate bill 59.
okay and
[Music]
so we're now on to the last bill here's
and
prime sponsor center hennessy oh she is
here okay great
good morning senator hennes
[Music]
good morning chairman hunt and honorable
members of the
commerce committee i really appreciate
your time this morning
and i have to say that was very
efficient coming in so thank you
um you guys are doing really well uh i
am here to introduce senate bill
97 oh sorry my name is aaron hennessey
i'm senator from district 1 covers
thornton all the way north through
pittsburgh
and chairman hunt would you like me to
introduce both
portions of the bill i am the prime
sponsor on both portions
yes that would be okay one after the
other
uh you're saying because it's because
it's two different issues
yes we're we're getting we had one
yesterday we're getting more used to
this is what how the senate does things
okay
okay so part one of the bill deals with
direct primary care providers and will
allow direct referral
to medical special specialists without
having to have the patient
go to another primary care physician to
get a
in-network referral and we have dr kopp
on the line who
is al is currently a direct primary care
provider in the state
and if you're not familiar with direct
primary care physicians
these are medical individuals that are
outside of the insurance network and
they
provide medical services for a fee on a
monthly
or weekly or annual basis
and this bill relates to their patients
who also have insurance coverage so
these would be in-network referrals
for the patient um and saving time for
the patients
where they wouldn't have to go to an
additional physician and money
ideally for the the health the overall
health care cost because
there wouldn't be an additional
physician visit
there was a compromise amendment made on
the senate side for this portion of the
bill
and i'm happy to take questions on this
part but i believe there's more people
on the line who would be better able to
answer your questions
yeah go ahead and you know discuss the
other part of the bill okay
part two deals with in-network retail
pharmacies
and the what we've seen with the
pandemic
has given rise the need for consumers to
shop in alternative ways
from curbside pickup to delivery to mail
order
this bill would prohibit pharmacy
benefit managers from restricting
in-network pharmacies from
making or from mailing or delivering
prescriptions
and allow patients to access their
medicines in ways that they are
comfortable
that they are comfortable with and we
have pharmacists on the line
to go into more detail and again i
believe there was a
compromise in this piece of the
legislation also
okay great uh is there any questions
from the committee members for
any of these two parts stupid yes
representatives
yes um thank you senator hennessey for
taking my question
um on the first part of the bill if you
have out-of-network providers
who are going to provide services to to
innate
network patients how do you ensure that
you have the same quality
and and cost um structure that you do
for people who are in the network so how
are you going to maintain that quality
and cost well it's um
i probably didn't explain it but it's
the patience the patient's decision to
have a direct primary care physician
and they paid the direct primary care
physician and they also purchase
additional health insurance and the
referral process is no different
the the scrutiny that the referral
process goes through is no different
as if an in-network a primary
so what would be the reimbursement rate
would it be based on what the physician
bills or
what the so the the direct primary care
physician does not get reimbursed
at all for this it is the um they are
making the referral so this
this piece of legislation has to do with
referral the
having the ability for a direct primary
care physician
to make a referral to a specialist that
is in a a patient's
insurance does that make sense so they
without having to go to another primary
care physician that is in the patient's
insurance
thank you very much you've just muted
yourself
and in sorry um
okay so um senator hennessy
let me get this straight so if somebody
has the money
to make a monthly payment to a doctor
that they think will give them better
service than if they went
in a network and
but this but and they have no
limitations as far as how often they see
this physician
is that correct i'm not sure what the
limitations are i think it would be in
that person's contract with that
physician okay
but the idea is that this doctor's
readily available
correct so the patient calls up his
his or her readily available doctor who
they pay
a monthly fee to and the doctor says no
no
you don't have to come see me i'll just
refer you to somebody in network
it saves money for that
so we say boutique doctor
and so they don't have to see them they
just automatically go directly to the
specialist
is that correct um no i
well yes and no in that and i and again
there's people on the line that can
answer these questions better
but the there still is the referral
process that they would have to go
through with the documentation
why does this patient need to go see a
neurologist
or an ent or what have you so
they they would definitely have seen
their patient to determine that a
referral is necessary
another question for the question may
inquire thanks very much
um oftentimes
referrals are done by phone is that
correct
i don't know the answer to your question
okay um
but if they don't have to have an
in-office appointment
so i i see where the confusion is okay
the direct primary care physician
takes care of the patient what what this
bill
would do would take out another primary
care physician
referral so right now direct primary
cares cannot refer
to a their patient's other insurance
program that they have
they're they're specialists so if i have
insurance but i choose to go to direct
primary care
i would want my insurance to cover my
specialist
the referrals to my specialists without
having to go to
additional primary care physician that's
in my insurance network
to then get another referral to the
specialist
thank you very much that helps yes
i think i got it okay so
um okay you have you you've made
reference to other people
which which who would you like to speak
next
who did you who oh um let's see
who's on the line dr crop
eric would you like him sure
okay and do i stay on or go off now uh
we we i generally i don't i won't throw
you off
um sometimes i'll move you over to the
attendees list so that you know
so you can uh don't have to smile i'll
i'll hang in there for
additional questions if needed okay
great all right
good morning good morning am i
you can hear me yes we can excellent
thank you
uh i'm eric crop i am a family physician
i do practice in the direct primary care
model i'm also representing
the viewpoints of new hampshire medical
society today
i'd like to speak to the bill in support
with a few um points and then i'm happy
to come back and address some of the
questions and answer any additional
questions um the medical society
supports this bill in general supporting
measures that improve
quality of patient care and lower costs
to an individual as well as the
healthcare system and
we feel that direct primary care is a
model that achieves these aims
we're really at a critical point in in
the practice of medicine and healthcare
and we're really moving in the wrong
direction when it comes to a lot of
things
one of our concerns is the ability to
effectively recruit and maintain a
stable primary care workforce
there was actually an article published
yesterday in the annals of internal
medicine
reporting that patients living in
counties
in the u.s with inadequate primary care
have a mean life expectancy of 310 days
shorter than those
living in other counties without such a
shortage there are a lot of studies in
around the world demonstrating
higher contact with primary care
leads to lower costs and better outcomes
and we know physicians and other
providers
in primary care especially are burning
out at really alarming rates
many are leaving clinical practice and
this just exacerbates the problem
um and you know on a more human level
physician suicide
is the highest rate of any profession
almost double the rate of the general
population so
at the medical society we really have a
vested interest in ensuring that
physicians are able to find sustainable
and
healthy ways to stay in practice and be
able to serve their patients putting
their patients
as their primary focus and and direct
primary care is one model that can do it
um report that i attached in my email is
one from the
the society of actuaries uh that was
completed
uh last year and it demonstrates some of
the concerns that have been
raised are really not true that direct
primary care which
i think most of you are familiar but
i'll just review it briefly
a flat periodic fee the national average
is
i think around 80 to 100 per month um
in order to provide primary care
services for the patient there's a
contract that is signed that defines
what services are covered
it clearly notifies the patient that
it's not
itself an insurance plan um
the rsa 329 the direct
primary care laws actually define what
has to be part of that so that patients
understand what they're getting into
when patients understand that and they
seek out a model where the
the doctor provider you know unburdens
themselves from all the insurance
uh administrative uh details and
um you end up with a a system with
better contact with more direct access
better availability
lower patient panels longer appointment
visits all those things that contribute
to
a better experience and better quality
for that patient
when patients are able to combine that
direct
payment to the physicians with a health
insurance product
that often has a higher deductible but a
lower monthly premium their monthly out
of pocket ends up being the same
depending how they utilize it their
their yearly expenses are often
significantly less
um it's it may not be intuitive but uh i
can go into as much detail
um as needed to to demonstrate that um
but it really has been demonstrated and
and the um and that that report goes
into into details
there's been no evidence presented that
this increases the cost of care costs of
premiums
that there are more inappropriate
referrals more patient complaints none
of that
has has been demonstrated um
the reason that this bill is important
is
really to create parity um
this direct primary care model already
exists these referrals already occur
for all medicare patients for medicaid
patients direct primary care physicians
who are not a network
contracted provider can do those
referrals and orders in medicaid
in ppo plans and epo plans in
certain hmo even anthem has hmo plans
that don't require referrals so
none of these have shown any kind of
deleterious effect
of the the physician not being a
contracted
member we're not asking for any payment
from these plans
none of that would change all we're
asking is that
patients who can't afford these higher
plans or who don't qualify for medicare
medicaid
can still be able to access the benefits
of direct primary care
that physicians and providers can
provide direct primary care
and we feel like this is going to
reinforce the patient's right to choose
it's going to help lower health care
costs and and we hope that you will
uh vote this ought to pass one um
comment that i just want to make is that
that currently there are only a small
handful
of uh direct primary care providers in
the state there
i believe six or seven physicians and a
couple of nurse practitioners
um uh there was an amendment um
to limit this uh as a trial
uh period um to 10
providers and i would ask that there be
a consideration
made to amend it to a larger number of
providers i
don't know what the growth will be but
um i would hate for
for this to be a factor that again
limits a physician or provider from
being able to
continue to practice clinical medicine
in a healthy way
so i'd be happy to to take any questions
at this time we do uh representative
abel has a question
yes thank you very much for your uh for
your testimony and
for joining us this morning um i'm
wondering
why i want your perspective
on why you believe
insurance companies are not already
honoring your um
honoring your referrals since you're not
asking them for reimbursement yourself
you're a qualified physician uh
you're not in their network maybe that's
the only reason
but i mean i'm gonna ask this to the
insurance company
people as well i don't understand why
uh why they won't
accept your referral for for
uh for reimbursement by it
to another doctor um it's it's an
excellent question
and it's one that you'll have to ask
them because i
i don't know why it doesn't make sense
to me and that's why
um i think this bill is important um
the the um
so i i'd like to hear that from them as
well
okay uh representative abramson has a
question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um you referenced an
amendment during your testimony
what was the uh age and line number for
the uh provision that you
on line 14 of
uh part one section
numeral one line fourteen uh certify the
first
providers
and um if i may make a comment as well
um the
regarding another change to the to the
amendment um
one of the the key reasons why direct
primary care works
is to basically distill down the
practice of medicine to the physician
and the patient
um now obviously physicians are licensed
and
and compliant with with um you know all
the regulations of the practice of
medicine and practicing to the standard
of care
but what direct primary care is able to
do is is reduce the administrative
burdens by not contracting with
providers and we return this
to the patients in terms of time and
access um
the direct primary care law
put the guidance the jurisdiction under
that of the board of medicine rather
than the insurance department by
clearly stating this model and the
requirements in order to
show that this is not insurance it's not
boutique or concierge medicine where
um if you're not familiar with the
distinction
a concierge or boutique practice will be
a fee for service practice that bills
uh usually to insurance but bills for
office visits
and also charges the patient
additionally
we don't do that in direct primary care
and
we would ask consideration that the
oversight uh
the serv the the certification as it
were that was
inserted as an amendment uh the
consideration be made to
rightfully put that under the board of
medicine statutes who have the
jurisdiction
for determining compliance with the
direct primary care laws
uh mr brannon could probably comment on
that
okay once again i just did my thank yous
um
two questions number one is uh in
regards to
medicare and medicaid is
uh do they allow you to
um make a ref reference uh a referral
uh medic i'm sorry was there more to the
question
yeah we just heard that there was a lack
of
usage and then then we heard that maybe
that's
from my perspective was that uh
you you can't make a referral to an
in-network
physician does that apply also to
medicare
and medicaid no medicare has a provision
to um to register with the pico system
as an opted out physician so i'm not
receiving payments
from medicare but with
proper licensure and national provider
identification and registration
they recognize that referrals and
ordering is part of the practice of
medicine
not the business of insurance and so
medicare does have that allowance to be
able to do that
there are some medicaid some of the hmo
plans in medicaid
um are restrictive and have not
permitted referrals from me
however medicaid itself permits me to
register as an ordering and uh
referring provider again that depends a
little bit on which
plan is being administered to the
medicaid recipient
um and it even goes so far with
with medicaid they won't permit me to do
the prior authorization
for for an mri that they will permit me
to order so
there's a lot of there there are we run
into these uh at different times
um and and it can be a little bit
unpredictable
and and that's part of what what becomes
challenging
uh to patients when they have an
insurance plan that is supposed to cover
this service at in-network benefits with
this specialist and yet they can't
access that
um so that that's
so it's so uh that answer
yes further questions so um
that answer sounded to me like sometimes
yes sometimes no
in terms of being able to make a
referral the other
the other thing uh this my second
question was
and i i'll just lay it out there because
i don't uh
i want to know from these insurance
companies
uh why well they're they're next so
okay that's that's a question for
another another expert okay thank you
very much
all right okay so uh thank you very much
doctor club
uh and and i have you listed twice right
you
signed up twice i think that that uh mr
padmore from the medical society
had signed in for me uh
prospect crossed wires there a little
bit so i didn't i want to make sure
there weren't two doctor crops in new
hampshire
okay all right uh so uh i'll now invite
sabrina dunlap from
anthem to um explain
why she is in opposition to this bill
to this week thank you representative
members of the committee i'm sabrina
dunlap director of government relations
at anthem and yes we do oppose the first
part of sb 97 and the amendment
um we're unaware of any problems or
barriers to care related to referrals
and
i mean generally if there's a problem uh
with our
you know impacting our members that
needs legislation we would have at least
heard about it
um we honor referrals now and it seems
like there's a perception that there's a
problem without an actual
problem uh so we've really questioned
the need for this legislation
and as for the amendment we're just
puzzled by it um
our system doesn't really know about
referrals as they come in so i'm not
sure how we'd collect information on
these direct primary care doctors
even if we could i'm not sure the
information would be timely or helpful
and i also don't know how we'd
operationalize what the amendment is
asking of us so so it's quite
problematic on a few levels
um and as a more general matter we do
have concerns for our members
as we see more happening in the direct
primary care space and potential for
confusion
for patients and as you you heard um
direct primary care is outside the scope
of the insurance regulations and
statutes and outside the scope of the
new hampshire insurance department
and really it's only for those who can
afford this model of care and i
mentioned
this to note that direct primary care
you know it functions in its own realm
and i'm not sure that's always clear to
patients
and i know that's sort of a bigger
picture issue on direct primary care but
um i did want to mention that is
something you know that we're very aware
of so
in closing i'd say this is you know i
see this as legislation
sort of in search of a problem and and i
think the amendment would actually
create problems so
we certainly hope this bill does not
move forward um
and thank you and i'm happy to take any
questions
okay we do have a question
currently as an insurance pro as an
do you uh
you're saying you do not require
the uh the original physic
the primary physician making the
referral uh be a member of your network
in order to ensure the patient
with uh with
with a specialist that that's um
that's a network uh or is the or
or is it that you prevent you will not
automatically take a referral to someone
out of network
i hope i asked that asset
in in a reasonable way but um
thank you for the question i'm i'm not
sure i understood the second part but
um i will say i mean most most
plans don't require referrals anyway so
we can
start with the fact that this is a very
small number of plans to begin with
um and my understanding of how
the process works is that um
you know a referral coming from in
network or out of network
or a direct primary care provider would
not be a barrier to someone
seeing a specialist who's who is in
network
okay a follow-up question yes
yes thank you um does this mean that
later that same individual that the
patient will be told
uh we're sorry you went to see the
specialist but the specialist wasn't the
network
so we're not going to cover you uh
that's when the that's when the patient
finds out
uh are you saying that's that's not not
the case
so i think i just heard you mention
specialists who are out of network which
is sort of a different
issue um i think than what's before us
but
all right um i'm happy to i am happy to
get down more in the weeds and follow up
with an email or or another conversation
i'm just not quite sure i'm
understanding
he suddenly muted himself oh you took
good thing i'm not a surgeon put the
all right so uh
a specialist sees uh i mean a patient
sees the
specialist in network uh
and there's there are no cases where
uh you then tell them that they can't
like that that never happens that never
happens with anthem
well i i would never say
never about anything but in general it
is my understanding that that's correct
that
if you see somebody in network who's a
specialist
um there's the distinctions with
referrals is not relevant
in terms of how that specialist is then
covered and they they would be covered
okay great um all right
uh so next up
samuel mccready
[Music]
and samuel if you just raise your hand
then i can find you there you are
okay
okay can you hear me yes we can thank
you hi um
samuel mccready um i'm a family
physician uh in gorham new hampshire
um i actually had some written comments
uh
that i had submitted and then i had a
brief summary of those that i was going
to present here
honestly i feel like dr crop pretty much
covered all of my points and so i don't
want to waste
the the committee member's time uh by
repeating the same stuff over and over
i would just reiterate the direct
primary care
is not the same thing as concierge care
it is not about cherry picking
wealthy patients or or any of that kind
of stuff
if that were the case i wouldn't be in
gorham new hampshire you know which is
probably the most economically depressed
area of the state
direct primary care really is about as
the name
implies establishing a direct
relationship with the patient
for the last i guess three and a half
years up until the late summer of last
year
i was employed in gorham by a federally
qualified community health center i was
an
in-network provider eric described a lot
of the
problems in the primary care space with
physician burnout and increased
suicide risks and all that and frankly
that's that's the direction i was
heading
um you know i was typical day for me
would be to show up at work at eight
o'clock in the morning
and work through lunch and leave the
clinic anywhere from
around 9pm until sometimes midnight the
majority of that time was not
spent seeing patients the vast majority
of that time was spent
dealing with paperwork and bureaucratic
requirements
that are part of the the fee for service
insurance driven system i'm not here to
get into the weeds of the insurance
driven system i'm not anti-insurance or
hate insurance or any of that
but just the simple reality is that the
system's broken i think everybody can
agree that there's some major problems
um and and direct primary care and
and these are thoughts that i that i
hear over and over when i talk to other
direct primary care providers around the
country
it's it's a safety valve it's it's a way
to say hey i still want to stay in
practice i still want to serve my
community and take care of patients
but man the current system is getting in
the way of that um you know and so
i left my job back in the summer a
couple of months ago i launched a
private direct primary care practice
um i i i have not been in the space
nearly as long as eric crop
you know so i i i'll refer any questions
over to him you know as far as
actual experience with with problems
with hmos because i personally haven't
been doing it long enough to really run
into any big personal problems
i will say that when i was an in-network
provider i certainly did there was an
awful lot of bureaucratic
red tape and you know having to get
prior authorizations and
you know you have a patient that's been
on a medicine for years and suddenly
they you know want that medicine changed
and stuff like that
you know if miss dunlap is saying that
anthem you know
isn't going to ever you know stop a
referral from a non-network primary care
provider
great that's good news to me i would say
if that's the case they shouldn't have a
problem with this bill you know if
that's their their position then they
shouldn't have a problem with it being
in the law
that they're not going to stop that
referral and at the end of the day
i'm about a mile right now my house is
about a mile from the clinic where i
used to work
in that clinic i supervised mid-level
providers nurse practitioners and pas
right now if one of my patients comes to
me and i say gosh
this guy needs to go see a cardiologist
and i make the referral
if the hmo says it has to be an
in-network pcp making that referral
my patient now has to go make an
appointment and see somebody down the
road who
a few months ago i was actually the
supervising physician for
to see if they'll agree with my medical
judgment and agree with that referral
you know as far as the the questions
that came up earlier about quality of
out out-of-network providers
you know i don't know what to say i'm a
board-certified family physician
i've been fully vetted by the state of
new hampshire and have a full and
unrestricted medical license
i have a caqh profile which is
basically a credentialing profile that's
public uh publicly available to any
insurance company
um you know they can go and they can
look at my credentials
my credentials haven't changed from you
know a few months ago when i was an
in-network provider
and they haven't changed at all you know
ultimately this is about basically
removing barriers to care
it's about being able to provide
patients with good quality care that
they can afford
again this isn't a concierge practice my
prices are on my website gorhamdpc.com
they're transparent they're very
affordable
and frankly you know i don't have it
officially written on the website but
i have never turned away a patient due
to inability to pay
and if someone showed up on my doorstep
tomorrow and said i'm homeless and have
no money but i
i'm you know need somebody to help me
with my blood pressure i'm going to help
them out
you know and and i think the vast
majority of family physicians
whether they're dpc doctors or not i
think the vast majority of family
physicians
feel that way you know if obviously we
all have bills to pay
you know and you know but if i were in
for the money i want to be a family
physician
there's much more lucrative and less
onerous uh
uh specialties to go into um again i
feel like dr
covered things much better than i am i
did submit written testimony which goes
into a ridiculous amount of detail
um yeah i'm happy to entertain questions
thank you any questions from
committee members uh cnn thank you very
much for your testimony
thank you sir okay so um
um heidi kroll
uh who represents uh the america's
health insurance plans
heidi
did i do it right yeah you're muted you
gotta unmute yourself heidi
there you go good good morning sorry mr
chairman i've
lost the connection there for way too
long for my comfort zone
um good morning mr chairman and members
of the committee
for the record my name is heidi kroll i
work at um
gallagher callahan and gartrell and i'm
here today representing america's health
insurance plans which is
otherwise known as ahip um we ahip
appreciates the amendments that were
made in the senate to try to improve
sb 97 however we do remain
opposed to part one of the bill um and
we would respectfully request that um
you find part one in expedient to
legislate
as you've heard a little bit about this
section of the bill deals with
so-called direct primary care physicians
and so direct primary care physicians
are pcps who choose
not to be in insurance networks or to be
part of insurance networks
instead uh direct pcps only serve
patients who have entered into
a special contract with them where the
patient agrees to pay a monthly fee
to the out of to this out of network pcp
and then the patient also agrees to pay
out of pocket for any services
that the pcp renders and as you've heard
under new hampshire law
the direct primary care contract is not
health insurance and so the patient
typically also has health insurance in
addition to the
special contract arrangement and so the
issue is
when an out-of-network direct pcp refers
someone to an in-network specialist to
what extent is the resulting claim
covered
and so this bill says that the claim um
should be should always be covered as if
the referral had been made by an
in-network
pcp um so it's important to note that
in-network pcps are first of all
credentialed by the carrier
credentialing cert certainly goes above
and beyond
just being board certified there's
actually statutory
requirements around the carrier
credentialing
providers that are in network and
secondly
pcps are often work under a value-based
care model which means their
reimbursement is tied to the quality of
care provided to their patients
and rewards both effectiveness of care
and efficiency
and so out of network direct pcps are
not credentialed by the carrier and they
are not operating under this type of
value-based care model
and so ahib's concern is that this bill
is trying to give providers who are out
of network
on the benefits of being in-network by
allowing them to make referrals to
in-network
specialists and then extending the
coverage benefits
to the resulting claims to the best of
our knowledge this type of legislation
only exists in one other state in the
entire country
and as af is concerned about several
negative impacts if the bill
um were to pass here in new hampshire um
first we were concerned that this bill
would undermine the carrier's ability to
build and maintain networks
um especially primary care panels within
networks
which will in turn erode the value of
networks for new hampshire citizens and
employers who pay the insurance premiums
as you know providers that join networks
typically
agree to price concessions which
translate into lower premiums and lower
costs for healthcare consumers
and in exchange for making price
concessions the net the in-network pcps
are given the opportunity to care for
the carrier's members
um including you know referring those
members to in-network specialists when
necessary and appropriate
um if direct pcps are given referral
parity uh there would be you know
no to at least a lesser benefit or
advantage to being an in-network pcp
and the concern is that in network pcps
would stop agreeing to the price
concessions and of course that would put
upper pressure on premiums and co-pays
and deductibles
for new hampshire's residents and
employers
in addition we're concerned that this
bill could cause problems with patients
care management and lead to fragmented
care
because you'll be trying to manage a
person's specialty care in-network but
the pcpu is ordering the appointments
with the specialist is out of network
um and you know again fragmented care
could also lead to upward pressure on
on health care costs i would also add
that one of the challenges with direct
primary care
is that as you've heard it is only a
choice for consumers who
who can afford to enter into these
arrangements and we think it's important
to be
just be careful that the choice of a
relative few number of people does not
drive up the cost for everyone else
um there's two final points i'd like to
make
one is that whether this is a pilot
program or not as you heard the
amendment turns this into a pilot
program
um carriers would need to upgrade their
systems to somehow
flag the direct pcps or put them in a
special category
separate from in-network pcps and
separate from
other out-of-network pcps who are not
direct pcps so that the claims generated
um when direct pcps make referrals
network specialists would be treated the
same as if the referral had been made
by an in-network pcp um and these system
upgrades
you know would result in additional
costs that would also need to be
recovered in premiums
um and finally you know there's been at
least some discussion that this bill
could save the insurance carrier's money
because patients who are
in these contracts with the direct pcp
will pay out of pocket for some of their
primary care services
um however a believes that any such
savings will be
more than offset by losing the value of
credentialed in network providers
by losing price concessions from
in-network providers
by increasing costs associated
potentially with fragmented care
and then by incurring the cost to
upgrade the systems in order to track
the claims
associated with referrals made by an out
of network
direct pcp and so for this reason for
these reasons
as opposed to part one of sb97 and we
respectfully request that you find part
one in expedient to legislate
um i appreciate your time and listening
to this
testimony and i'd be happy to try to
okay we do have some questions
representative herbert is
has a question thank you chairman hunt
um thank you uh
um mr scroll or miss carl um
[Music]
it's been said that uh that every this
this business is covered in mental
health uh care
is uh insurable and and is insured
um but then at the same time the
uh spokesman said spokespeople said
we're a little surprised that it isn't
being utilized
a lot and i'm just curious as to what
you might think
may be the cause of something not being
utilized that is
everybody agrees needs to be far
better utilized my question is do you
have any idea why it's not being
utilized
so representative are you referring to
the
collaborative care model that was
disgusting
yes i'm referring to this legislation
because
there's i'm getting two different
answers it sounds like to me
and that is one from the direct care
physicians
and that is that they cannot
make referrals and and then the
insurance company is saying
well one of the insurance
representatives said well no that's not
an issue at all
and but i'm hearing from you that it
most definitely is an issue
so i'm trying to get i'm trying to get
everything straightened out in my own
mind
yeah and i think i you know i think that
certain plans are
you know there's a variety of plan
options and so
you know i think as you've heard there
are plan options where
a patient does not need to worry about
where the referral is coming from
whether it's coming from an in-network
pcp
or an out-of-network pcp and i guess i
would say that if you're
if you're one of those patients who can
afford
um to engage in
in an arrangement like this where you're
paying a monthly
fee i think we heard earlier somewhere
between 80 and 100
a month and you're also able to pay out
of pocket for
any services that are provided to you by
that pcp
um and then you want to be able to have
uh
kind of referrals coming from that
pcp then i think you know you have the
option
i think there are products out there in
the market that you could
um purchase for insurance products where
you would
not have to worry about where the
referral is coming from
i the only answer i get other part of
the answer i guess i have for you is
that maybe
not everybody feels like they can afford
that extra
100 a month and paying for the the pcp
thank you okay representative mccleary
thank you chairman and i may have a
follow-up
um um miss kroll do you have any idea
how many out of
network dpc doctors there
are in new hampshire um
i have not done that research i'd heard
um during the testimony in the senate
that there was somewhere in the
neighborhood of
four to six um so i'm
but i don't know that information
directly based on my own research that's
only what i heard
in that case would it not be much of an
impact
i mean there's only four to six
physicians that would be affected it
would seem to me that
by uh approving this bill
uh it really wouldn't make that big of a
deal
am i wrong on that well i think i think
the issue is that you know again if
you're
a patient using these direct primary
care physicians
um then like i said there are insurance
products out there that you could
choose that would like like the
representative from anthem indicated
they have
products that it doesn't matter where
the referral came from whether it came
from an in-network pcp
or an out-of-network pcp and so if that
if that's important to you then that
could be you know then you could
those products are out there for you to
purchase but i think the issue is that
for
for certain products that are structured
so that the referral does
matter those networks have been
designed with that um
[Music]
criteria um or characteristic in mind
and so
this gets back to the kind of the value
of networks
where um you know you've you've
um you know that relationship between
the carrier and the provider where the
provider is making concessions in terms
of
pricing and reimbursement in exchange
for
um the the privilege i guess
to manage the care of the patients that
are in that product
um and so i i think that's part of the
concern and
also as i mentioned um at least some
pcps are operating
under value-based care management models
where their reimbursement is tied to
how well and how effectively they're
managing the care of their patients
and that care includes appropriate and
necessary
referrals to in-network specialists and
avoiding
referrals that are not necessary and not
appropriate and so
if you all of a sudden interject um an
out-of-network
direct primary care physician who all of
a sudden starts making referrals
um that's gonna have a financial impact
on that in-network pcp
um and it's something the in-network pcp
has no control over
so i think it's just trying to respect
that um
there's a variety of of products out
there in the market
and um you know as the um sabrina dunlap
from from anthem indicated
we don't really see that the legislation
is necessary
thank you great uh representative
abramson
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question maybe this is
uh the same question i'm looking at uh
page one of the bill part one
part two where it says an insurer shall
not apply deductible coinsurance or
co-pay
co-payment greater than the applicable
deductible coinsurance or co-payment
that would apply the same health care
service if
the service was referred or ordered by
an in-network participating
primary care provider so on one hand
it's saying
you can't charge you can't charge more
for the out-of-network provider
but isn't that the same as saying that
you can't charge less
for an in-network provider
under the same role are you saying okay
we can no longer offer you a discount
um yeah i mean i think the issue here is
um kind of the heart of this bill
is that some insurance products may be
see a specialist and have that service
that the specialist provides and the
claim that's generated from that in
order to have that
covered under the benefits of your plan
the referral to that specialist needs to
come from an in-network pcp
and so and if it came from an
out-of-network pcp
then the services provided by that
specialist would not be covered in
certain products in certain insurance
products and so i think what the bill is
trying to do is
say toss all of that out the window
um the claim will always be covered
under the
under the benefits of the product no
matter where the referral came from
um so and that's that's kind of
where the rub is very nice
okay uh representative
thank you mr chair um just a quick
uh question do you think insurance
companies
are managing family physician practices
um
i guess we're we see them as partners
in you know i mean p primary care
physicians
you know have the ability to join
networks or not join networks or
join networks with certain health
insurance carriers and
not join other ones so um if they choose
to join
um then we i think we see them as
partners in
thank you okay thank you um so uh
dr crub i'm gonna have you speak uh at
the end here to
because you've already spoken but uh
i'll let you speak again later but
but right now i just want to get to her
attendees list because we're now at
noon hour uh so next up
is i will have the insurance department
speak so
tyler you just moved on me
okay all right thank you
so tyler brennan from the new hampshire
good afternoon tyler hello so
tyler brennan with the new hampshire
insurance department
um so i'm going to address just i think
than the main
points that differ from prior testimony
and
just to give you a little background on
the direct primary care model
um we actually have a law in the books a
provider contract standard that says
a health care provider can't balance
bill a member for anything but
regular cost sharing because of this
provision
it makes it almost impossible for a
direct primary care provider
to be in network so in other words if
the direct primary care provider was
getting paid fee for service and
collecting a membership
fee that membership fee could be seen as
balance billing the member for something
more than regular caution
so that's the dynamic that results in
these providers being on a network
a few years ago there was legislation
that came forward
to clarify that these arrangements are
not insurance
because if you're an unsophisticated
consumer you might sign up with a direct
primary care provider
pay a monthly fee and think well great
that's a good alternative to health
insurance i'm fully covered
of course as soon as you need specialty
care then
you're not covered for those services so
the legislation that came forward to
move
the kind of oversight of the direct
primary care practices
and put them into the medical licensing
statute
the insurance department had that
preference because we're an insurance
regulator we're looking at insurance
products or making sure they meet
standards that are associated with
insurance products
the board of medicine will at least in
the past has said that they are more
comfortable in
looking at clinical standards than
administrative standards nevertheless
that's where the requirement is
so as long as the the direct primary
care practice follows the guidelines
which are largely based on consumer
notification making sure the consumer
knows what they're signing up for then
they can proceed and not be pursued by
the insurance department for selling
insurance
the um i think the department doesn't
have a position on the bill we do have
some concerns about how things would
play out
and that's largely because of the way
benefit designs have existed for a long
time
um you may remember kind of the
reference to the primary care provider
is the gatekeeper
so the idea was if you went to see the
gatekeeper you wouldn't be going to a
specialist and receiving specialty care
that would be more expensive
and that specialist operating within
their their realm of comfort
offering services that perhaps were
unnecessary so you go to the primary
care provider you get treated there
and if you go directly to a specialist
without seeing your primary care
provider
getting that referral from that
in-network primary care provider
then you may not actually have any
benefits when you go to the specialty
care
so i think to the extent that products
are being offered that allow the kind of
flexibility
for you to go to directly to specialists
that is certainly responding to perhaps
consumer demand to be able to have that
kind of flexibility
but i can't help but wonder if there
isn't going to be a cost impact
in other words the premium for those
products might be a little bit higher
so when you have legislation like this i
think it's worth recognizing that the
benefit designs that require a member to
select an in-network primary care
provider
essentially would be overridden by law
so there's certainly some operational
and documentation
changes um probably substantial ones
that would need to take place
and the other concept of having an
in-network primary care provider
that is managing the patient's care the
insurance company through that
relationship with the primary care
provider
can influence the primary care provider
so
obviously keep the referrals in network
don't refer to an out of network
specialist
but also perhaps refer to the most cost
effective specialist
one way they may do that is say well
primary care provider
if the overall cost of the patient's
care on average
is less than a particular benchmark you
get some kind of financial reward
if you've got a direct primary care
provider is that a network that
relationship with the insurance company
doesn't exist
the direct primary care provider may not
hesitate to send you to the most
expensive provider
in state having no incentive to kind of
maintain
your care within what it could be the
most cost-effective providers
dr crop did refer to a society of
actuaries study that came out last year
and i think the findings were
interesting in there so they took a
large self-funded employer
and basically gave those employees the
option to select a direct primary care
provider
and and have that for that provider
managing the care
and it did not show the inflationary
pressures that might exist
a number of the reasons that have been
articulated about why physicians go into
direct primary care arrangements
are probably quite valid the flexibility
they have the avoiding the
administrative requirements
and i think that finding alone would
suggest that further research is
appropriate
but more importantly insurance companies
should look at the arrangements they
have with primary care providers
are they overburdening them is the
expectation to see number of patients
too high
are these these these these management
structures
actually creating greater costs for
their population
i mean you could see this as a
competitive area shouldn't the insurance
company if it's going to look at their
competitive position in the market say
well how can we improve what we have
with primary care providers lower the
cost overall
the model with primary care has changed
a lot over the years and indeed in the
past there have been even
primary care capitation arrangements so
pay that primary care that in-network
primary care provider
a monthly fee for managing the patient
care
so it's worth at least acknowledging
that there have been some explorations
in terms of how to best manage the
relationship with the primary care
provider
but indeed i think we are a long ways
from from from any
real solution at this point um
there is a provision that ended up in
the amendment about the insurance
department
reviewing up to 10 of these contracts
these are contracts between the
primaries the direct primary care
provider in the member
to ensure that they are compliant with
the requirement that is in the physician
licensing law
this is a strange place for the
insurance department to be
but i think i know where it came from
there was a direct primary care study
committee
and a big big part of the interest of
that committee was
keeping track of what was going on with
direct primary care practices
and the insurance department was asked
about some sort of certification
and um we said it wasn't our preference
at the time we do feel as though the way
the bill is
is amended we could probably do it
within existing resources
that being said it's going to be a
compliance review not an in-depth
legal analysis about whether or not the
member's contract meets the standard
so just kind of note that that out there
um
i think the the other thing that's in
there is that report on the impact of
the legislation in 2025
uh similarly we could we could probably
do that report within existing resources
and it might be an interesting analysis
at that point
so just to summarize it it does
represent some significant changes to
the way
products and benefits are managed there
are some cost concerns because
that relationship between a carrier and
a primary care provider
should lead to the most cost-effective
treatment but i think you've heard some
or potentially valid concerns about how
things have developed over the years
i do want to say uh briefly about part
two on the bill
and i raise these concerns and this is
the the pbm requirement
i raised these concerns in the senate um
the way new hampshire insurance laws are
structured
most of the time pvms are subject to
insurance laws
as really as a contractor with the
insurance company so put in a
prescription drug requirement for
insurance
companies the pbm is also bound by that
requirement
a few years ago maybe only two
legislation passed creating a pbm
specific
chapter so the definition of a pbm for
that chapter
is a pbm that does work for multiple
current carriers
so you could have a pbm that does work
just for one insurance company
and they're not included in the pbm
chapter requirements
today those requirements are basically
the same doesn't matter if you're a pbm
serving one insurance company or
multiple insurance companies
but this new provision although
relatively minimal
would just apply to pbms that are
servicing multiple insurance companies
unless you also put the exact same
requirement insurance
chapter so uh for insurance carriers and
i have the language um so if you proceed
if you want to proceed with the
legislation or at least part two
and you don't want to create a different
standard on that based on that dynamic
um you may wish to amendment the bill
that way so i'll stop there and i'm
happy to take any questions
great any questions from the committee
members
uh thank you very much and we appreciate
your testimony
thank you okay i have one more name
signed up and before and then i have
andrew osmer wants to
weigh in and and dr krupp i promise
wouldn't speak again
so rick newman
rick you want to raise your hand and pop
up to the top for me
okay rick you just have to unmute
yourself
got it thank you mr chairman uh
members of the committee my name is rick
newman and
i am representing the new hampshire
independent pharmacy association i
assure you i'll be
very brief i would like to speak to part
two of the bill
that is i believe very simple it simply
prohibits
a pbm or adds to the prohibited
acts for pbms they cannot
stop retail pharmacies from mailing a
prescription to a
to a patient we've discovered this to be
a problem
there are patients that for various
reasons want to use a retail pharmacy
and may at times not always
but may at times need uh the service of
having
a uh prescription mailed and they're
willing to pay a fee to have it mailed
and uh but there are some pbms that then
will tell the retail pharmacy
they will not get reimbursed for that
prescription this um
change will uh stop that practice
allow the occasional mailing by a retail
pharmacy
to a patient and i would just say that
the comments of the insurance department
we agree with if they feel it needs to
be added to another
section duplicate language which often
is the case we certainly have no problem
with that
and i would just uh it appears from
listening
that part one may have some controversy
i don't really believe
part two does so i would hope the
committee
would um look favorably on part two and
if that means
you know finding another home for it
should some other action be taken
regarding part one we would certainly
urge you to do that
i'm happy to answer any questions mr
chairman uh evidently we do have a
question representative abramson has a
question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question just be clear you're
speaking in favor of
part two and you'd like to keep uh part
two in the bill
that is correct part two all right thank
you very much
all right more questions are all set
okay um and
former senator hussmer uh you want to
weigh in
thanks very much uh mr chairman and and
i will be brief
uh certainly uh good afternoon uh
chairman and members of the committee my
name is andrew hosmer
i represent harvard pilgrim healthcare
which is uh as you know the largest
nonprofit insurer in new hampshire
uh i am uh testifying on their behalf as
opposed to section one of sb97
um certainly harvard pilgrim health
healthcare is um
uh our focus is quality care for all our
members and we're certainly willing and
anxious to collaborate with all the
stakeholders
uh in discussing uh direct primary care
just the concerns that we have here and
i don't want to be redundant because i
think miss kroll and miss dunlap and
certainly tyler brandon raised all the
relevant points that
i had hoped to but our healthcare
delivery networks have been created to
ensure
coordination of care and patient safety
with the pcp at the center or as a
as a gatekeeper as it was testified to
earlier what we have found
is that this leads to lower costs as
members are receiving the right care
in the right setting so i i we don't
stand here
pushing back against innovative ideas
when it comes to health care
all i'd ask the committee to consider
right now is that there are plenty of
opportunities for improvement in our
healthcare delivery networks
um or our healthcare delivery system but
i think the networks have been created
to make sure there's quality care
delivered to members and make sure that
there are some cost
controls in place and it's a delicate
balance to manage
so before we go forward and start pilot
programs and expand
how we're going to treat direct primary
care providers and their referrals
i think really we should take a step
back and slow down and look at the
impacts particularly potential cost
increase prices that the department of
uh insurance has indicated may occur
so with that i will conclude my
testimony if you have questions i'll do
my best to
uh i think the committee members are
hungry
so i think we're all set all right thank
you very much so
uh dr crop we'll let you have the last
word
thank you i'll be very brief i
appreciate dr brandon clarifying a lot
of the the earlier questions i had
i just want to make sure that in this
discussion that people don't
lose sight of the patient in this
equation
uh in any business quality and value are
measured from the customer perspective
and
and that's what the patients are we we
need to make sure that that we're taking
care of them
and you know you talk about things that
are confusing
uh health insurance reading your
benefits from health insurance can be
can be pretty confusing and it i think
it's a little disingenuous to say that
dpc is not affordable when my patients
are paying
14 000 a year as a healthy
60 year old woman for her insurance
and having a 10 000 deductible that's
that's pretty unaffordable
and and what we're trying to do in this
is is look outside the box get out of
that
that belief that the large healthcare
organizations
and the insurance companies and
everybody knows how to do this and how
to make this work for patients well
you start by asking the patients and
when my patients sign a contract
directly with me
and i say this is what i'm going to
provide for you and they continue to be
my patient
that's their indication that this is a
good quality care
um and so i hope that people you know
just keep in mind
hey how do we how do we make patients uh
how do we help them get
better quality care um
and and simplify things and and not
drive them away not
not treat them like numbers uh reduce
that problem that we have in this
country of using specialty care instead
of primary care
all those very expensive parts of this
primary care doctors are paid the least
our our expenses and our costs in health
care are the least of any other
uh segment and and you know i think that
this
this really could help kind of shift
that whether it's for five doctors in
this state or
500 patients or whatever the case may be
i think this is
this is important for those individuals
and um
i really appreciate your time and i
appreciate the the opportunity to to
speak one more time thank you very much
representative hunt
yeah all right um seeing
no more hands up and
i think we're all set um so
this bill had 20 people in support two
opposed and to
neutral and i will close the public
hearing
on senate bill 97
and so otherwise for the committee we'll
meet again next tuesday at nine
and i have not scheduled anything for
wednesday
um and then the following week um
obviously is the week bedford so no i
did not schedule anything
um for the uh for tuesday